Tim Ferriss: Hello, boys and girls, ladies
and germs. This is Tim Ferriss. Welcome to
another episode of The Tim Ferriss Show. We're
getting close to 700 episodes. Crazy to think.
And my guest today, long overdue, is Jason
Calacanis.
Jason Calacanis: Calacanis. There it is.
Tim Ferriss: Don't leave out the second A,
folks. He has invested in more than 300 startups
in the past decade, who is Sequoia Capital's
first scout and is the author of the book
Angel. He also hosts two podcasts, we're going
to talk quite a bit about, This Week in Startups
and All-In. You can find them online at Calacanis,
that's C-A-L-A-C-A-N-I-S.com and on Twitter
@Jason, because he was an early bird on the
Twitter platform. Jason, nice to see you,
man.
Jason Calacanis: It's nice to see you, brother.
You and I have random phone calls for an hour
or two and I think this is the first time
we're actually recording it.
Tim Ferriss: First time.
Jason Calacanis: The first time we're actually
recording it, which is great. I listened to,
I would say, two out of three of your episodes.
You've had a lot of investors on.
Tim Ferriss: I have.
Jason Calacanis: Somebody's like, "How come
you haven't been on Tim Ferriss' Podcast?
I'm like, "He's got so many investors on,
what can I add?" I'm sure at some point —
Tim Ferriss: There's a lot.
Jason Calacanis: I'm sure. But it is so great
to see how well your podcast has done over
the years.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, thanks man.
Jason Calacanis: I remember the first time
I met you in Tahoe with, I guess Sacca. He
was like, "Hey, this is The 4-hour Workweek
guy." And I was like, "Do you know how hard
you're making my life? All these founders?
Now they think I work four hours." I was breaking
your chops.
Tim Ferriss: It's part of the charm. It's
part of the charm.
Jason Calacanis: Good to see you.
Tim Ferriss: It is good to see you. You, I
consider a master of podcasting. We're going
to come back to that, because I have some
other questions maybe before that. But I wanted
to give an example of a great piece of tactical
advice. And you actually told me about this
before we started recording. QuickTime. So
we are both running backup QuickTime audio,
so we have extra local copies in case something
breaks, because things often break. What was
the tactic that you shared? Because it's so
smart.
Jason Calacanis: You load a QuickTime thing
and you're like, "Hey, can you start a QuickTime?"
People go, "Oh yeah. My QuickTime's running."
But then one out of three times, at the end
of the show we're like, "Okay, can you upload
the QuickTime?" They're like, "Oh, I didn't
hit the record button." So instead of asking,
"Can you record a QuickTime?" I say, "How
many seconds is your QuickTime running?" And
they say, "It's been 36 seconds." Now I know
it's running. But the bigger piece is there's
this book, The Checklist Manifesto, you and
I are obsessed with, probably part of our
kinship.
Tim Ferriss: Atul Gawande.
Jason Calacanis: Yeah. We're both into tools
and optimization. And this book, I had heard
Jack from Twitter would give it to every Square
employee, give it to every Twitter employee,
The Checklist Manifesto. And I make everybody
read it, I'm obsessed with checklists, because
people forget. And all those great stories
in the book about surgeons and pilots were
like, "I don't need a checklist." And then
everybody dies. And then a nurse comes along
and was like, "I could just make this little
checklist for you and you say something. I
say, 'Okay.' You say something. I say, 'Okay.'"
And then all of a sudden you could have a
plane with four engines because people had
more discipline.
Tim Ferriss: And it's like, "Oh, I know you
guys didn't need this checklist, but we have
bacterial line infections down by 39 percent
this year." Go look at that.
Jason Calacanis: People would take a scalpel
that was dirty and they made this little device,
these little life hacks that are so much a
part of what you do. And by the way, super
weird for you to tell me that I'm a podcast
master because I take notes on your podcast.
Anyway.
Tim Ferriss: It works both ways.
Jason Calacanis: They would put a little tent
on top of the clean instrument, so a clean
scalpel would have a tent on top. And the
nurse was responsible for cleaning everything
and putting the tents on, so then they knew
it was clean. And you take the tent off, now
it's been used. So "Tent on" means "Clean,
don't put the tent on a dirty scalpel."
Tim Ferriss: Tent off, no bueno.
Jason Calacanis: No bueno.
Tim Ferriss: Now, you can't believe everything
you read on the internet, so please correct
me if I'm getting any of this wrong, but either
your mom was tending to people in the ER,
your dad had a bar, as I understand it. There
were times when you would be cleaning blood
off the floor from all the brawls and fights.
Jason Calacanis: That's a true story.
Tim Ferriss: And then raided at one point,
I think, by the, I don't know if it was the
FBI, but with —
Jason Calacanis: Tax authorities.
Tim Ferriss: Tax authorities.
Jason Calacanis: My dad got a little behind
on the taxes.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. The taxes, they sneak up
on you.
Jason Calacanis: It turns out the tax authority,
they're humorless. You pay your taxes or you
go to jail. And so when I was 18 years old,
growing up in Bay Ridge, Brooklyn, which is
the last stop on the train, just to give you
an idea of how far out there it is. This is
the '70s and '80s. In 1988, my dad's bar,
after the stock market crashed, he went into
basically debt and it was really gnarly. And
then one summer afternoon in July, the feds
basically and the tax authority came and padlocked
the place, took everything out of it, and
this close to my dad going to jail, and had
one of the great traumas of my life.
And that is one of the things I really appreciate
and respect about you is you shared your trauma
on this podcast. It's like a gift to the world.
That's a pretty scary thing when you're 17
years old and your dad says, "I'm sorry, son.
I don't have money for college, I'm probably
going to jail. I tried to make this business
work, it didn't work. Take care of your mom."
Whoa. It's like that scene when, if you remember
in The Empire Strikes Back and Han Solo comes
over to Chewbacca, he's like, "Just take care
of the Princess. I'll be back." It was really
intense. Really intense.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Yeah, I bet that's —
Jason Calacanis: Crazy. My life just got crazier
and crazier after that. So I forged such a
crazy childhood that was so violent and crazy
and just Brooklyn, when it wasn't cool, that
it made when I went into business, I was like,
"I don't have to worry about somebody jumping
me? There's no violence here? I'm not going
to be murdered? I'm not going to jail?" It's
like, "Wow, this is easier." But I didn't
know that world existed. The only world I
knew was the people who hung out at my dad's
bar, the Mafia, the Hell's Angels, a bunch
of cops, some percentage of which were in
on the take with the other two groups, and
then a bunch of Wall Street people. And so
it was like out of a film like Goodfellas.
Tim, I kid you not. I would have to go serve
espresso to the bookie or the dealer or the
head of the Hells Angels. It was bonkers.
It just made me really good at dealing with
people, I think. And having a certain —
Tim Ferriss: I would imagine you developed
a lot of situational awareness.
Jason Calacanis: Adaptations, right? You get
a lot of adaptations real quick when you're
dealing with those different types of individuals.
But I look back on it now and I'm like, "Did
that really happen?" And then I look back
at what's happening in my life now, and I'm
like, "Is this really happening?" So it's
been a pretty surreal life the whole way,
I have to say.
Tim Ferriss: If we flash forward a little
bit, and we don't necessarily have to spend
a ton of time on this, but Silicon Alley Reporter
in the beginning, you're photocopying it yourself,
you're hand-delivering it to coffee shops
and other spots. Did you know or decide you
were going into business for yourself to be
an entrepreneur? And I ask especially given
what you saw happen to your dad. I can see
some people responding by going entirely in
the opposite direction, getting the safest
nine-to-five possible. So how did you end
up an entrepreneur?
Jason Calacanis: Having a dad who was an entrepreneur
puts it in you. And I had one or two jobs
when I was in college. I went to college at
night. So I would fix laser printers and build
networks. This is before the internet existed,
you would have to connect computers together
with coaxial cables and create what's called
a local area network. And I did a couple of
those jobs and it was well-paying and it helped
me pay for college, because remember my dad
had no money, so I had to pay for all this
on my own. It took me five years to go through
school at night. But when I would ride the
train in, I would look at people reading magazines
and then I would go to cafes, pre the web
and mobile phones. And we would go hang out
in cafes in the Lower East Side, Bleecker
Street, wherever, the Village. When I was
at college, we'd go play chess on Bleecker
Street or read magazines or free newspapers.
And I just looked at the people who were in
the pictures, Tim. And I was like, "Why are
they on the cover of the magazine? Why is
this person on the cover of Spy magazine?
Why is this person on the cover of Paper magazine?
Why are people important?" All I knew was
nurses, doctors, lawyers, cops, firefighters,
that's all I was exposed to. I didn't understand
there was other stuff in the world. Then I
went to school in Manhattan at night and I
would work in Manhattan during the day, and
I was looking around going, "Who's that person
getting out of that limousine to go into that
big, tall building? What's in that big tall
— oh, those are apartments?" It was really
weird, like being dropped on an alien planet
because Brooklyn was so different than Manhattan
at the time.
Tim Ferriss: For sure.
Jason Calacanis: Brooklyn was a bunch of blue
collar people, Manhattan were rich people
and powerful people. And so something just
clicked in my brain and I said, "I want to
be powerful, I want to be rich, I want to
be on the cover of a magazine." And I started
looking at the magazines and then I discovered
the masthead. And I saw the masthead and I
said, "Wait a second. Who's the publisher
and the editor-in-chief? Who has more power?
Who is this editor-at-large? That sounds more
important. But wait, it's in a smaller font
and lower." And then I started to meet people
and I started asking them, "What's this? What's
that?" And I was at a party and I ran into
somebody at Barneys. Somebody had invited
me to a party in the basement of Barneys.
And I'm talking to this guy and I said, "What
do you do?" And he says, "I work at a magazine."
I said, "What magazine do you work at?" He
said, "Paper…"
Tim Ferriss: Let me pause for a second. Barneys
sounds fancy. How did you get invited to the
party?
Jason Calacanis: You know what? I just was
hanging out in the downtown scene where a
company called Voyager was making CD-ROMs,
Blender was making CD-ROMs, a friend of mine,
Josh Harris, was doing Pseudo and he was doing
online chat rooms with Prodigy. So I was just
hanging around with the tech scene there,
and it was probably 50 people who were in
the tech scene. Because the only thing that
existed were online services, dial-up, CompuServe,
Prodigy, The WELL. It was just a small set
of dial-up services and I knew how to use
a modem and I knew about the internet. So
started to meet those people, and then those
people started to tip over into the media
business in New York, because the media business
was very attracted to, "You can dial up and
read an article?" People started to put these
connections together, magazines plus a dial-up
service, music plus a dial-up service, booking
a ticket to a movie, a dial-up service. And
a CD-ROM has a video on it or it has an article,
so you could make a CD-ROM with an article
end.
So this multimedia thing happened and then
I was at Sony setting up their computer networks
when the internet happened. And then Sony
was going to build a website and so I was
on the website team. And the website was a
picture of 10 Sony logos, Sony Music, Columbia
Records. We literally sat 10 people in a room
designing a webpage with 10 logos on it. That
was the entirety of the website, it was one
page, and then a 12-page legal disclaimer.
So this was a very interesting moment in time.
And I said, "What magazine?" He said, "Paper
magazine." I said, "You work at Paper magazine?"
And he said, "I created Paper magazine." I
said, "What do you mean you created it? You
work at the printer?" He said, "No, no. I'm
the editor-in-chief. I'm David Hershkovits."
I said, "Tell me everything." So I start talking
to him. He says, "Why don't you come by my
office, because I'm setting up my dial-up."
And I said, "Okay." And I go down to his office,
which was where Balthazar is now at Lower
Broadway. And I help him with his internet,
and we're talking about dial-up services.
"You should write a column for us about the
internet and this technology stuff." So I
started writing for Paper magazine. And I
was this little nerdy kid. I didn't know how
to write, I didn't know how to spell, I didn't
know how to put a comma in a sentence.
So Christine Muhlke was my editor. She was
20-something years old, I was 20-something
years old. I started writing for Paper magazine.
And then Hershkovits, he was really getting
into the internet. And I remain friends with
him to this day, 30 years later. And he would
just ask me to come by the office to hang
out. I'm hanging at Paper magazine and he's
like, "Hey, you want to go to a concert tonight?"
"Yeah, sure." He says, "We're going to go
to the Roxy. This new band, Chemical Brothers
is going to be playing. Orb is going to be
opening for them."
And then we're in the green room or the VIP
room waiting to go on and he's like, "Jason,
meet this woman from Iceland." And I'm like,
"You're from Iceland. Where is that? Is that
Norway or Sweden?" And she's like, "No, it's
over here." And just talking really low. And
I'm like, "So what do you do?" She's like,
"I have a record coming out." And I'm like,
"Oh, that's awesome. What kind of music? Is
it like these guys?" She says, "No, just I'm
a singer." I said, "I'm Jason." And she goes,
"I'm Björk." This is New York in the '90s.
It was cool as F. It was the zeitgeist was
crazy. So all of this starts to spiral and
I just said, "I need to make a magazine."
And David had showed me the early issues of
Paper. And Paper magazine was originally —
Tim Ferriss: I've never heard you censor your
cursing before. That was very delicate of
you.
Jason Calacanis: It's a family show, I think.
Tim Ferriss: You can curse. It's okay.
Jason Calacanis: Don't tell a kid from Brooklyn
to start cursing. Your poor editors are going
to be — you just created three hours of
editing.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, boy. Search, replace. We
have 47 fucks in the first 30 minutes. All
right. Good.
Jason Calacanis: 47 fucks given. So anyway,
it's actually fun to remember all this stuff.
So he takes me to the archive room of Paper
magazine, which was a glossy at the time.
And he says, "Look." It was a foldable thing.
I got a foldable piece of paper and I folded
it and we would just put it for free in cafes.
You know in The Terminator, you see from his
view and all the words are going by and he's
just processing everything really fast, that
was happening in my brain. I was like, "Okay,
wait. Free, fold it, print it. What? Okay.
Do this." And I'm taking all of these instructions.
And I literally went to Tower Records, which
is a place where they used to sell CDs and
records and they had a zine section. And zines
were short for magazines, Z-I-N-E, for people
who are under the age of 40.
And this was the most punk rock thing you
could do, after being in a punk rock band,
was to start a zine. And a zine just meant
you got your friends together and wrote an
article together and then you would photocopy
it. So 2600 famously was a zine about hacking
in New York. And I had met the founder of
that. So there's a little zine culture going
on and I was like, "Huh. All my friends are
starting the internet stuff, I'm writing about
the internet once a month, I write 400 words,
I could write 40,000 words. I can write 4,000
words, whatever." And people had never been
to San Francisco or Silicon Valley, but somebody
referred to what we were doing as Silicon
Alley. And I was like, "Silicon Alley? That's
rad." And then I was like, "I should be a
reporter about Silicon Alley. I could do a
Silicon Alley Reporter and it would just be
me reporting on what's happening here because
this is cool. Now, it's 200 people doing stuff."
And so I just started a photocopy called Silicon
Alley Reporter. And I went up to the Village
Printing Shop on 43rd Street and Sixth Avenue.
And every time I'm in New York, I like to
walk when I'm in New York just to remind myself
of those moments in time. And I always walk
down that block to see if it's there. Village
Printer, I know it's still there, a couple
years ago it's still there. And it was 24
hours. And I brought it to the guy and there's
a thing called tabloid paper. Eight and a
half by 11 plus eight and a half by 11 equals
whatever it is. The 17 by whatever.
And you could take that paper, fold it, and
put a staple in the middle and it would look
like a newsletter. And so I said, "Okay, that's
the format." I got PageMaker, I started laying
it out, I took pictures, I wrote a couple
articles, and I went there and I printed it
and he said, "It's going to be 10 cents a
photocopy." And I was like, "All right. 80
cents an issue, I could do this." So I go,
I said, "Make me a 1,000 copies, 800 bucks,
right?" And I'm just going to start handing
them out like David Hershkovits did. And I
go and he hands me a bill for 1,750. And I
said, "Wait, you said 10 cents. It's eight
pages." He said, "It's double-sided." I said,
"It's double-sided." I said, "I don't have
the money." He goes, "What do you mean you
don't have the money? I got a thousand copies
of Silicon Alley Reporter here."
And so I start talking to the guy. Now I'm
haggling with him. And he's just the overnight
manager. And I said, "Listen, I don't have
the money for this. My credit card's maxed
out. Can you do me a favor? Maybe someday
I could do you a favor. I could put an ad
in there." And he's like, "Don't tell anybody,
okay?" And I was like, "No, I won't tell anybody."
He's like, "They got a counter on these things.
I could get busted." And I was like, "I don't
want you to get busted." He's like, "I don't
know, man. This thing's really cool. Just
give me 800 bucks." And I just gave him 800
bucks.
Then I realized, I started to learn a very
interesting lesson in my life that when I
ask people things, that many times people
will do what I ask them to do, like a Jedi
kind of trick, but this guy did it out the
kindness of his soul. But I started to learn
early in my career, you could ask for things
in the world, even sometimes outrageous things,
and sometimes it happens. And I took them
over to Roseland where there was a internet
party going on for — Roseland's a venue,
a music venue. And then some electronic music
person had played and then a bunch of internet
multimedia people were going to be hanging
out.
So I walk over there, I had dropped off mostly
issues at my little office I had. A little
office-share. And then I took 200 of them
in my backpack and in my hands to the party.
I get to the party at 1:00 in the morning,
and I just start handing them to people. And
I had this moment of clarity in my life. People
started coming up to me to get them. And then
I turn around and I look at the party, which
was popping off. And every single person has
the magazine open, the zine open, the photocopy,
and is reading it with two or three people
around them. The entire party stopped.
Tim Ferriss: So what did that feel like? What
happened to you when you saw that?
Jason Calacanis: Power.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, okay. Tell me more.
Jason Calacanis: I got the power.
Tim Ferriss: You got the power. Tell me more.
Jason Calacanis: Remember I said I had no
power as a child, and they take your dad's
bar? We're going deep into the trauma work
here. Listen, I consider it a privilege to
be on here and you've shared a lot and if
this helps other people, but when you don't
have power and you're a kid and you live a
scared life, which I did, and then all of
a sudden the entire party in Manhattan is
in the palm of your hand and something you
created has stopped everybody dead in their
tracks, the adrenaline and the confidence,
it felt like all of a sudden Superman figures
out when he reaches into the fire to get something
he dropped and it's like, "Oh, the fire doesn't
burn me? Whoa. I can fly?" Just these incredible
wings sprouted. And I was like, "Wait a second.
I could be an entrepreneur. I could do something
in the world."
And the next day I was at it. My phone was
ringing, people were calling me. And then
I just made a set of postcards that said,
"Subscribe to The Silicon Alley Reporter.
10 issues a year, $90." And I had seen Esther
Dyson charged $1,000 for her newsletter. So
I was like, "She's Esther Dyson. So if I charged
10 percent, maybe that's the same thing."
Esther Dyson was this famous Angel investor.
When I went out, if I didn't have the magazine
on me, I had the cards and I'd just hand the
cards. And then within two or three months
I would get to my office-share and there would
be a stack of envelopes and it would be 20
people sent me $90. It's $1,800.
Tim Ferriss: Mailbox money. What a feeling.
Jason Calacanis: Every day, $4000, $6,000.
And all of a sudden there was 30, $40,000,
people subscribing. And it was like the Kevin
Kelly, "You only need 2,000 true fans." And
then all of a sudden I was like, "Wait a second.
I can quit my jobs. I can do this. I'm David
Hershkovits and Kim from Paper. I did it."
And I was like, "Whoa." And this all happened
within 60 days. From a nobody trying to get
into a party to meet somebody, to all of a
sudden every CEO and person trying to meet
me. And it was basically, this all of a sudden
becomes the Sliding Doors moment of your life.
Some random occurrence happened, I meet David
Hershkovits at a party. I get this guy to
print out the things, I go to that party and
drop them off, and all of a sudden I'm important.
But remember, I wasn't covering tennis, I
wasn't covering wine, I was covering this
new thing called the internet when the browser
didn't support graphics. So the timing was
so insane because the intern — you talked
about this Forrest Gump thing, now that's
a problem. This is going to stick. Everybody's
going to be like, "I guess life is like a
box of chocolates, Tim." I just turned into
the Forrest Gump of the internet industry,
it's going to stick forever. I'll take it.
I'll take it. Forrest Gump had a great life.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah. He did. He did.
Jason Calacanis: That was the start of a great
life for a very simple man.
Tim Ferriss: I'm so glad we're talking about
the early days because, of course, I had no
idea of a lot of this stuff.
Jason Calacanis: But you had the same thing.
Nobody knew who you were, you were some guy
and all of a sudden this 4-Hour Workweek goes
from — you got paid nothing for that book
and then all of a sudden — wasn't it the
same exact experience?
Tim Ferriss: It was similar. It was similar.
Yeah. It was very similar. I remember when
the book came out and I got a call from my
editor, Heather Jackson, at the time. And
she said, "Why, hello, Mr. New York Times
Bestselling Author." And I had just finished
a day of radio satellite tours, which people
did back in the day. They may still do them.
And I'd had two pots of coffee and I was just
exhausted. And I sat down on the floor and
I said, "Heather, don't fuck with me. I'm
too tired." And she said, "I'm serious. No,
you made it. You're 15 on the extended list.
Not in print, but you're on the list technically."
And I thought, thought to myself, "Oh, wow.
Things are about to change. Things are about
to change."
And all of a sudden, let's call it within
the next few weeks, it kept growing and then
it stayed on the print list for, I want to
say, four years plus unbroken. And in the
beginning, I started getting these calls asking
me to speak, offering to pay me for keynotes.
None of this had happened before and it was
—
Jason Calacanis: Mind-blowing.
Tim Ferriss: — bewildering. Yeah. Very bewildering.
Jason Calacanis: The speaking gig is an interesting
moment because you work your whole life, you
make 30 grand, 40 grand a year, and then this
kind of stuff happens to you. And then somebody
calls, "Oh, Tim. Would you like to come speak
at this corporate thing?" And you're like,
"Why would I speak there?" "Oh, well, your
book." And you're like, "Okay." And they're
like, "Of course, we'd like to give you an
honorarium." And you're like, "Okay." And
they're like, "And it's $30,000," or "40,000."
Whatever. And you're like, "That's what I
made last year."
Tim Ferriss: Come again? Come again?
Jason Calacanis: "$3,000?" "No. Add a zero,
30,000." And you're just like, "That makes
no sense." And they're like, "It's going to
be two hours of your time. We don't want to
put you out, Mr. Ferriss." And you're like
"Can I do it tomorrow too?" It is a mind-blowing
experience. I've literally just had one of
these come in today, some corporate gig. Because
All-In's gotten so popular, all of a sudden
now people want me to speak at a bunch of
stuff again. And it's just the numbers are
mind-boggling. And you're just like, isn't
it very weird how you can go from being an
absolute nobody to somebody wanting to give
you tens of thousands of dollars to speak
for an hour? That really screwed with my mind
a lot. Also, because I had a lot of feelings
of guilt and stuff about my parents. And I
was like, "You're offering me a speaking gig,
which is what my mom or dad made in a year."
Tim Ferriss: In a year. Yeah. It's weird.
Jason Calacanis: You also had this —
Tim Ferriss: Same situation. So weird.
Jason Calacanis: It really does screw with
your head and it's very hard to stay grounded
or figure out what's actually happening, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Let's talk about another
"Holy shit" moment. And this is January of
'99. You're offered —
Jason Calacanis: You've got all the moments.
Tim Ferriss: — 20 million, I believe.
Jason Calacanis: It's a true story.
Tim Ferriss: I'm reading here, this is from
Fast Company and it talks about your interaction
with —
Jason Calacanis: Alan Meckler.
Tim Ferriss: I think this was with I think
Douglas Rushkoff.
Jason Calacanis: Oh, Doug Rushkoff. My friend
in New York. That was another guy who taught
me so much. I love Doug.
Tim Ferriss: Walk me through getting this
offer, the conversations you had, the decision
you made, and then if anything you take from
that to this day, if you wouldn't mind.
Jason Calacanis: The magazine had gotten very
big and it became a color glossy. I had almost
a hundred people working for me. It was 300
pages and it was during the dot com boom.
Talking about 1999 now. So the magazine is
doing six, seven, eight million a year. I
had done an event or two that started making
two or three million. So now I've got an $11
million company, I built up my credit cards
and I was making, just a couple years earlier,
minimum wage to work in the computer room
at Fordham, which was $3.50 an hour. And then
I was fixing laser printers for $9 an hour.
And then I got a job at Amnesty International
doing their internal network for $12 an hour.
So all of this happens in a very short period
of time. And again, for a poor kid from Brooklyn,
I'm just trying to navigate it.
And this guy, Alan Meckler had internet.com,
he took it public, it became worth a billion
dollars and he offered me 20 million bucks
for Silicon Alley Reporter. But it was my
identity and it was making 10 million. And
I was like, "I don't want to give up my identity."
But I thought about it, I said, "If I can
clear a million or $2 million a year off the
magazine in profits, it'd be the same amount
of money. So maybe I wouldn't do." And then
the dot com bust happens and I lose everything.
And I wound up selling the scraps of the business
to Dow Jones. And they give me two years of
salary and the magazine's dead. And I get
two years at $300,000. It's maybe five or
$600,000 in this employment agreement. And
they paid off all the bills because I then
had, like my dad, I was in arrears when the
magazine collapsed.
If you've got a magazine about the internet
and the internet collapses, literally not
only —
Tim Ferriss: Tough business.
Jason Calacanis: — not only did I not have
any money, all the money that was owed to
me never showed up, because all the companies
had gone out of business. So I was like, "You
owe me for three ads." They're like, "Phone
number didn't pick up." The company was shut
down. And so then I show up for work at Dow
Jones and they say, "Hey, can we take you
for a walk?" It's middle manager guy. And
I'm like, "Sure. Walk? Okay, sure. We'll go
for a walk." We walk. "Hey, listen, you're
so talented. We don't think — you being
here and you're so talented." And I'm like,
"Yeah?" And they're like, "So you should go
do something else." And I'm like, "Are you
firing me?" And they're like, "Yeah, we don't
need your services." I said, "You just bought
my company and the 20..." I had 20 people
left and I reassigned them to this other venture
capital thing they were doing.
And I said, "You don't want me, Jason Calacanis,
the Silicon Alley Reporter, to work here?"
They said, "No." I said, "I just signed a
contract with you for five or $600,000." They
said, "Yeah." And he pulls out an envelope
and he hands me a check for $500,000. He says,
"We're paying out your contract." Tim, you're
the first person I've told these stories to
really. This is literally the crazy life I've
lived. And I am looking at a $500,000 check,
which is a extraordinary amount of money,
obviously. And the only thing I can think
is, "I want to beat the shit out of this guy.
You just fucking fired me? You don't want
me. Who went from being a nobody to running
New York, being on Charlie Rose, being on
the cover of The New York Times, having a
New Yorker thing being written about me, just
living the peak New York experience.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: Living in a loft in Manhattan,
sitting in the first three or four rows of
the Knicks games, hanging out with Allan Houston,
the number one star on the Knicks of the time.
I mean I was living it, the peak. And then
overnight boom, everything's gone. I got a
500k check in my hand and nothing. Nobody
wants me. And I got so — the rage that I
felt in that moment was Hulk-like rage. I
was a berserker. The samurai armor, just took
the sword out and I was like, "I am going
to prove I can do this again. I am going to
show everybody that this was not a fluke."
It made me — I've never felt more rage in
my life, I don't think. And I've been in some
pretty big brawls. And so then I just went
and I took the money and then I just went
back to my, I got an office and the next day
I said, "I've got to build something. I've
got to build something."
Tim Ferriss: The next day.
Jason Calacanis: The next day I was like,
literally got an office share with my friend's
office. I said, "Can I — you got a desk?"
And it was like that blank sheet of paper
in 2000, 2003. "I've got to figure something
out. What's next?" And I just started making
designs on whiteboards —
Tim Ferriss: I was going to ask, that day,
how do you even begin with such a blue sky
—
Jason Calacanis: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Blank page. How did you even
start? Were you just pulling from random bits
and pieces floating around? Did you have some
approach?
Jason Calacanis: Approach? I started calling
people up. I started calling people up, "What
are you working on? What's happening?" And
then this one person was making this photosharing
site, Flickr. Another person was doing a bookmarking
site called del.icio.us. There's just this
little underground of people who were building
stuff for the web because the web had gotten
advanced now in the second decade.
And it do — the webpages could refresh themselves
with Ajax and there were kind of tables, it
became more responsive and there were all
these new technical things and editorial formats
people were playing with. And I was like,
"Huh, who's doing anything?" And then there
was this one group doing journaling on the
web. There was another group that was trying
to do photosharing and follow your friends.
And I'm just like, huh. And then I had somebody
who had worked for me named Rafat Ali and
he had started a blog —
Tim Ferriss: Let me interrupt for one second.
So the reason you're calling these people
is not because you want to work with them
on what they're doing necessarily or was it?
Or were you just trying to get read of the
landscape?
Jason Calacanis: No, it's literally just trying
to network with people who I had known and
I was literally asking people, "What's going
on? Is anybody doing anything cool?" And I
just started looking for people doing cool
projects just to see what was going to happen
after the dot com bust because everybody quit
and everybody went and got jobs at big companies.
Tim Ferriss: So you're trying to get a read
of the playing field to see where the pucks
might be going next?
Jason Calacanis: Exactly. Is there anything
interesting —
Tim Ferriss: I'm mixing my sports metaphors,
but you get the idea. Yeah, I'm talking about
field hockey everybody. Yeah. Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: Let's just say Tim Ferriss,
when he learns a sport, it's wild to watch.
Watching him first learn a sport is hilarious
because I taught him how to do a layup.
Tim Ferriss: It is. It is funny.
Jason Calacanis: Taught him how to dribble
basketball, it was hilarious. That's another
story.
Tim Ferriss: It is funny. And also if you
learn a sport with J Cal, you are going to
have to listen to so much shit —
Jason Calacanis: I'm going to torture you.
Tim Ferriss: He will torture you at every
opportunity. Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: Watching Tim Ferriss go from
being a perfect fencer or perfect yoga in
negative a hundred degrees and then he tries
to dribble a basketball, it's literally like
looking at a drunk person with a blindfold
on.
Tim Ferriss: Oh yeah.
Jason Calacanis: But to your credit —
Tim Ferriss: True story.
Jason Calacanis: I watched you learn how to
do a layup and I gave — you asked me like
three or four questions and you went from
looking like you were blind and drunk to all
of a sudden doing a layup in under three minutes
perfectly. And I was like, yeah, that's Tim
Ferriss' gift. He knows how to ask the right
questions and I'm watching you process. It
was actually impressive.
But anyway, it was one of those moments where
you're like, "What's next in the world?" I
was just trying to figure out what was next.
So I was just — because also so many people
were out of work that if you couldn't get
a job, you kind of just started tinkering.
Which is kind of how multimedia started. So
it was like, I've seen this before. Technology
keeps going, people are starting to tinker.
And Wi-Fi had come out at that time, I was
very fascinated about Wi-Fi and I was thinking
about Wi-Fi routers and putting Wi-Fi in places
and maybe you could have internet in cafes
and stuff.
It was just all kinds of crazy little ideas.
And I started whiteboarding stuff. I started
— Kozmo had gone out of business, the delivery
service. So the first idea I had was for Mercury
Club. And I was going to get a hundred New
Yorkers and give them Mercury Club number
one, two, three, four, five, all the way to
a hundred. I was going to give one to Charlie
Rose, one to Howard Stern. And my idea was
to get a bunch of people on Vespas, because
I had gotten a Vespa and I was driving around
New York and I realized, because I had driven
one in Barcelona, I was like, this is the
way to — if you're in a city, a bike's too
slow, a car's too slow, and a Vespa goes fast
because you can just weave in and out of traffic.
And I had seen Kozmo had started experimenting
with Vepsas and I said, "I'm going to create
a service where you pay a hundred dollars
a month for rich people and you get four hours
of deliveries, 25 bucks an hour."
This is when minimum wage was six or seven
bucks. But this is only for rich people. And
if you needed a bottle of wine or pack of
cigarettes, whatever, you would just call
an 800 number. Because 800 numbers were another
platform, they became zines for a while. 1-800-FLOWERS,
1-800-MATTRESS, 1-800 everything. And so I
started looking into buying a 1-800 number
because I was just always very interested
in mediums, right? Because if you get to a
medium first, you can exploit it. Whether
it's podcasting like you and I did, or blogging
like I did and you did, I think, or zines.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Started in 2005, blog.
Jason Calacanis: Yeah. So if you get to it
first, you get to play with it first. You
get a disproportionate amount of credit for
being there first. Just if you go to Austin
first or you go to, Bed-Stuy Brooklyn, first
you get the cool loft that you bought for
nothing and then everybody else comes and
your loft goes up in value. So the value of
the platform goes up as the people who tinker
and create it get to play with it. So I never
really actually thought about it, but it is
true. And so I also got the 800 number. 1-800-MERCURY,
I was trying to get a Mercury Club number.
And my idea was the — because remember I
was talking to the guy who had done Kozmo,
because I covered it in my magazine. And he
said, "Yeah, I should have just charged a
delivery fee."
Because the last six months they started charging
a delivery fee. And he said, "Yeah, the business
worked in three of the nine cities. If I had
only charged delivery fees," I was like, "Why
didn't you?" He's like, "The VCs told me not
to, wanted to grow. I'm trying to get public."
It was just literally the same lesson people
are learning now. So I was like, well wait,
instead of charging a delivery fee, why don't
I just make it — because I knew bike messengers.
Bike messenger culture was a big thing in
New York. So bike messengers used to hang
out outside where my loft was because it was
business commercial loft, the Starrett-Lehigh
Building in New York. It was commercial and
we were living there illegally. Me, DJ Spooky,
a couple of artists were living in these illegal
lofts. Anyway, the bike messengers were out
there all the time.
They were always smoking weed. And it was
a very cool culture because they had figured
out life. They made nine or 10 bucks an hour,
they would make 10 bucks per run. They could
do two runs an hour. And they got to just
bomb these bikes all over Manhattan. And they
got exercise, they were fit, they were smoking
weed, listening to music. It was like the
coolest gig ever. I was like, these guys,
they figured out life. You get to ride your
bike all day, smoke dope, listen to cool music,
joke with your friends, and you just drop
off an envelope now and again. And you make
more money than the people you're dropping
off the envelope to, which are outside. It
was just a crazy revelation I had. So I was
like, yeah, I'm going to do Mercury Club.
And I built the whole business model for Mercury
Club and then I was watching the blog —
Tim Ferriss: How did you land on the name?
Jason Calacanis: Well, Mercury the god with
the wings on the feet and I just came to,
I was Greek. I always liked the Greek gods.
So I was just like kind of started thinking
about fast and I just thought, well this would
be incredible. Can you imagine you're like
Charlie Rose at a party or David Hershkovits
from Paper and you're just like, "Oh, should
we get cigarettes?" "Yeah." And you just pick
out your — because mobile phones had come
out at that time. So imagine taking out your
StarTAC, and I had seen a StarTAC phone, those
little flip phones. It's like imagine you
take that out and you dial an 800 number and
you say, "Yeah, I need two packs of Marlboro
Lights and bring me a copy of Vanity Fair
or Esquire magazine, because I'm at a party,
I want to show somebody," and then just somebody
comes there and hands it to you? The ultimate
luxury, the ultimate power move. I can just
call my assistant and just get anything I
want. Anyway, I didn't wind up building that.
Tim Ferriss: So, Greek. Your name is Greek.
What does your last name mean?
Jason Calacanis: Yeah, so Calacanis means
"to have done well" or "good for you." So
sometimes when I use my credit card and a
Greek person does it, they're like, "Good
for you," or "You've done well, very nice."
But it's with Ks. So when my grandfather went
through Ellis Island, God rest his soul, they
were like, "Calacanis, here's your banana,
keep moving." And he was like, "No, it's Ks."
And they were just like, "Fuck you, Calacanis."
Tim Ferriss: "Here's your banana."
Jason Calacanis: No, they used to give bananas
at Ellis Island, I understand.
Tim Ferriss: What? That's real?
Jason Calacanis: Yeah. It was some weird thing
where they just would give everybody who comes
in a banana, because they were hungry off
the boats and bananas were, a lot of bananas
were coming in from South America to Ellis
Island as well. So they'd just be like, "Have
a banana."
Tim Ferriss: Today I learned.
Jason Calacanis: Keep it moving. And then
the crazy thing, Tim, is I was on the Ellis
Island website and on the Ellis Island website
I searched for my last name and they had archived
everything. And Calacanis, my great grandfather,
or my grandfather rather, went through 12
times. And it turned out he was in the Merchant
Marines. He was an inching captain. He wasn't
— and I knew that, but every time he came
back to America with human passengers, he
had to sign in again. And so he has gone through
it 12 times. It was quite a weird —
Tim Ferriss: That's wild.
Jason Calacanis: And I was like, wow, he's
coming from Brazil, he's coming from Ireland,
he's coming from Italy, he's coming from everywhere
in the world. The cargo was humans, it was
Americans.
Tim Ferriss: Human cargo.
Jason Calacanis: It was human cargo. It was
pretty crazy, right?
Tim Ferriss: That's wild.
Jason Calacanis: Anyway, then I watched the
blog stuff happen and two people who had worked
for me, Xeni Jardin was my event producer.
She had been working for a famous law firm,
Latham Watkins, and then she came — they
were a sponsor of one of my events. She did
a great job at the event. I asked Latham,
"Can I hire her, because she's awesome and
rad?" And I hired Xeni to come work with me
at Silicon Alley Reporter, she would produce
my events. And then when everything shut down,
she started working on this Boing Boing thing.
And I'm like, "Boing Boing? What are you doing
with your life?" She was like, "Yeah, we write
blog posts." I'm like, "Blogs? Blogs?" And
I was like, "Like Rafat Ali was doing?" This
kid who had worked for me, Rafat Ali was doing
a blog on the site called paidContent.org
and somebody ratted him out when he was working
at the magazine that he was moonlighting.
Now, back in the day, you couldn't have a
side hustle, that was instant firing.
So I call him into my office, I'm like, "You
got something to tell me kid?" He's like,
"No." And I'm like, "You sure you don't have
anything to tell me?" He's like, "Is it about
paidContent?" And I'm like, "Yeah." I'm like,
"What are you doing?" He's like, "I'm just
writing about people who are charging for
content on the internet." I'm like, "Hey kid,
information wants to be free. Nobody's paying
for content on the internet." He goes, "Actually,
I think you're wrong." "Hold on, kid, let
me stop you. Number one, nobody's paying for
content. The whole reason we started the internet
is information wants to be free. Number two,
you're not a great writer. I'm your editor.
Who's your editor for paidContent.org? And
he goes, "I don't have an editor. It's a blog."
I'm like, "No publication will ever work if
there is not an editorial structure. It will
fail because there'll be spelling errors.
You're going to write stupid headlines. You
need an editor. That's how this works."
He's like, "Am I fired?" I'm like, "No, just
focus on work and stop doing stupid shit on
the weekend. Get back to your desk." And I
just like admonished Rafat. Now I'm an investor
in this company now, Skift. But that incepted
in me because when we shut down, I had talked
to Xeni and I talked to Rafat and Rafat was
like, '"Yeah, I'm making four grand a month
on ads." I'm like, "I was paying you 35k,
you're making 4k now? You're making 48,000?
You're making $13,000 more than when you worked
for me." And then Xeni's like, "I'm getting
a 5k draw a month." I'm like, "What?" I'm
like, "How many hours a day do you work?"
She's like, "Look, I do like two hours in
the morning, and then at night I come home,
I do two or three hours." She's like — this
is before The 4-Hour Workweek revolution.
I mean, this is during the 60-hour reality
of being a worker. And I was like, blogs,
huh? And then I started reading blogs and
I was like, there's something here. Blogs
are dope.
Blogs, even though they have spelling errors
in them, come out faster than magazines and
newspaper articles. They're faster and faster
is always better. It's faster. I said, and
for the right writer, it's spicy. Like "Ooh,
Xeni's spicy." And I remember I wouldn't have
let her write that. I would've stopped her.
And then I checked, just when I saw all the
magazines and everybody had them, I just all
of a sudden, The Terminator, everything clicked
at once, Tim. I was like, it's faster and
it's better. It's faster, it's better. It's
cheaper. Faster, better, cheaper. Wait, I
had heard Marvin Minsky and Kevin Kelly and
all these guys at a conference, a TED at some
point talking about faster, better, cheaper.
I didn't understand what they meant, but literally
was at TED and they were at one of Brockman's
dinners and they were talking about "Faster,
better, cheaper, whatever, pick two."
And I didn't understand what they were talking
about, but it kind of another Inception moment.
I was like, wait a second, what if you had
a hundred of them? So then I called Brian
Alvey, who had worked with me on the magazines
and I said, "Let's go to the next game." And
went to the next game. And I said, "What if
we had weblogs?" The blogs were originally
called weblogs, because they were on the web
and they were logs. And then people dropped
the W E and they became blogs. You remember
all this? But a little history lesson for
those listening.
And so I was like, what if we did weblogs
for business? Nobody's ever done a business
topic, so we'll do weblogs. And he goes, "Oh
yeah, we should call it Weblogs, Inc." And
then he got the domain name and then we started
building them and we did a weblog on Wi-Fi
and we did a weblog on Apple. And then we
started building all these ones. And in under
18 months we had built 87 blogs, we had $200,000
in total revenue and AOL bought it for $30
million. And we had one investor, my friend
Mark Cuban had put $300,000 in for 20 percent
of the company or something. And I gave him
six million back. And then Brian and I and
Peter Rojas split the rest. And in 18 months
after my 20 million offer had gone away, I
got the 30 million offer.
Tim Ferriss: That's just insane. That's just
insane.
Jason Calacanis: And the berserker insane
J Cal, "I'm going to prove it to the world,"
proved it. And then I was like, yeah, I just
looked at the sword. I took the armor off,
hung it up, and I was like, "Yep, I can do
it. I can do it anytime I want. Anytime I
want, I can build a brand, a business and
I can just get it from zero to whatever."
I may fail two out of three times, but I could
do it. And that was when it was like, okay,
once you're lucky, once you're lucky twice
—
Tim Ferriss: Once you're lucky, twice you're
good. Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: It was my once you're lucky,
twice you're good moment. Because then everybody
who had watched me fail and kind of danced
on my grave at Silicon Alley Reporter was
like, "Oh God. J Cal did it again."
Tim Ferriss: The cat came back the very next
day. We thought he was gone, but he wouldn't
stay away.
Jason Calacanis: There's a lot of people who
are just like, "Oh, he's going to be insufferable
after this." They weren't wrong.
Tim Ferriss: They weren't wrong. They weren't
wrong. So just a couple of maybe boring housekeeping
questions. I'm thinking of the timing of building
these weblogs. How did you find the writers
to do this?
Jason Calacanis: A great thing for people
to understand right now, in this moment of
time, we're taping this in 2022 with the market
crash and Facebook laid off 11,000 people
yesterday. Yeah. I don't want to date this
too much. I don't know when you're going to
release it.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, that's okay. It'll come out
reasonably soon. But as a snapshot in time,
also crypto is having a complete implosion.
FTX is oing through the meat grinder. People
are probably going to go to jail.
Jason Calacanis: Yeah. Jail, 32 billion eviscerated.
I actually wanted to talk to you about people
who commit fraud and lie because I was interested
in your perspective on it.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: I just can't imagine it because
the system is so easy to win and the system
is set up for entrepreneurs to win in this
country. Why on Earth would you cheat if it's
so easy to just have a win by just working
hard? Anyway, putting that aside.
Tim Ferriss: But I interrupted you because
you were tying the weblogs and —
Jason Calacanis: Oh, the writers. Yeah. So
it was very simple. Everybody was out of work.
And so when you hired a writer, you'd say,
"Do you know anybody?" And the original deal
was we started going to people who were doing
LiveJournal blogs and we'd find somebody who
had written a blog about Apple, Sean Bonner.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, Sean Bonner! Yeah, yeah.
Jason Calacanis: And I said, "Hey, Sean, I'm
doing this Weblogs, Inc. thing, we're going
to try to sell ads on blogs." He's like, "Well,
that's stupid." I'm like, "Yeah, but I think
I could figure it out because I did a magazine."
He's like, "All right, that's pretty smart."
I was like, "I see you're writing some Apple
blogs. Could we put them on our Apple blog?
Or if I gave you the login, would you post
them?" Because Brian Alvey was a genius. He's
now running WordPress for Matt Mullenweg.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, no kidding.
Jason Calacanis: WordPress, like Pro, VIP
like people like you and I use.
Tim Ferriss: At Automattic. Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: At Automattic. So anyway,
he was a great collaborator of my career.
He's kind of my George Harrison or he's my
Paul to my Lennon or vice versa. And he had
built the software that was better than everybody's,
better than Typeform, better than Blogger,
better than everything. And I just gave Sean
the login and I was like, "Listen, I want
to pay you something because I want to own
the blog posts." He's like, "You want to own
a paragraph of me writing about a MacBook?
It's three sentences, Jason, it's worthless.
I'll do it for free." And I was like, "I'll
tell you what. How many a day could you do
about Apple products?" He's like, "Two." I
was like, "Okay, two, 60, I'll give you 150
bucks a month, cash, to just let us run these
over here. It's a paragraph each."
He's like, "I can write these in 10 minutes.
You're an idiot, but sure, I'll take whatever
it is, two or $3 a blog post." And so we just
then just started hiring people, and then
we made five bucks a blog post, eventually
10 bucks a blog post. And people thought we
were stupid because minimum wage at the time
was 10 bucks. And people were like, "I wrote
three blog posts this hour and you gave me
$30." But I had done a spreadsheet with Brian
and I said, "Here's how many page views we're
getting. Here's what I think we can make per
page view. Here's what the cost is per blog
post. All we have to do with this business
is scale it and then somebody will buy it."
And he said, "Yeah, I think you're right."
I said, "You do the tech, I'll get the writers
and the advertising. I'll see you on the other
side." And we both put our heads down for
18 months, and we had 450 bloggers in the
system, of which maybe 200 were active. And
we were pounding out thousands of blog posts
a week across 87 different topics. And then
AOL found out about what we're doing. And
they had looked at Gawker and they had looked
at us and Engadget was crushing Gawker because
we stole Peter Rojas from Gizmodo. It's a
whole other story.
Nick Denton and I had quite a rivalry for
a while. It was a fun rivalry too. But Peter
Rojas was actually the missing piece with
Brian Alvey and I, and once we got Peter Rojas,
he taught us like, "Hey idiots, just come
up with a name for the blogs. I don't want
to be gadget.weblogsinc." So then we made
the apple.weblogsinc, The Unofficial Apple
Weblog, TUAW, T-U-A-W, which people fell in
love with. People were addicted to TUAW because
at that point we were doing eight or nine
blog post a day about Apple. And Steve Jobs
read it. And Jony Ive and everybody and then
Engadget became a juggernaut. And it was just
a very simple business. And at that time,
$30 million was the equivalent of hundreds
of millions now.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, for sure.
Jason Calacanis: It was a different era.
Tim Ferriss: It's still, I mean, 30 million
today would still a lot good chunk of change.
So let me flash forward and I want to ask
you specifically, because it came up already
about events. So you seem to love producing
events and you've produced a lot of events.
I only produced one event —
Jason Calacanis: In Reno.
Tim Ferriss: It was very, very —
Jason Calacanis: Oh, Tahoe.
Tim Ferriss: It was in Napa long ago. And
it was so —
Jason Calacanis: I have a friend who went,
she loved it.
Tim Ferriss: It was a great event. It was
—
Jason Calacanis: People still talk about this
event. Somebody brought it up last year.
Tim Ferriss: They do. They do. And it was
opening, it was called Opening the Kimono,
OTK. I actually have a wine bottle from that
event over there. Because we had a wine making
competition that the participants all engaged
in. And then we took the winner and we bottled
whatever it was, 200 bottles and gave them
to everybody. So it was incredibly elaborate.
And I came out of that feeling like I had
just finished a tour of duty. It was so hard.
Why do you love doing events and what is the
smart way to do it? What is the J Cal recipe?
Jason Calacanis: So in the Myers-Briggs, I'm
going to say you're INTJ or INTP.
Tim Ferriss: Nailed it, INTJ.
Jason Calacanis: Yeah. But I could see you
being a perceiver. But anyway, I'm ENTJ. And
so you and I vibe until such time as I absolutely
exhaust you, and you need to go to your room
and take a deep breath. That's the relationship
between INTJs and ENTJs. This is for people
who don't know the Myers-Briggs, which is,
or as we call it, astrology for men.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that and Enneagrams. Astrology
for men. That's basically it.
Jason Calacanis: We don't believe in astrology,
but we believe in this other thing where we
answer questions and it tells us things we
want to hear about ourselves. But anyway,
I scored 86 and a hundred percent on entrepreneurship.
I'm sorry, on extroversion, the two times
I took it. So I'm so extroverted that when
I'm with an introvert like yourself, or say,
Evan Williams, a friend of ours, I can burn
people out. I want to talk for seven hours.
And when I've been on vacation with Tim Ferriss,
it's like Tim Ferriss was like, "Well, that
was an interesting 90 minutes with J Cal,
I need to go write for four hours," or whatever.
You need to recharge your batteries.
Tim Ferriss: Take a nap.
Jason Calacanis: Take a nap, whatever. And
if I talk for seven hours, I want to talk
for five more. I just can't go to bed or I
want to start working. And so I think you
have to understand your format, I think the
reason why you are the number one guy in podcasting
is because this format works really well for
you. You take a lot of time to think about
it. You do your 90 minutes and then you got
a lot of time to decompress and process. For
me, I do my show five days a week and All-In
six days a week. I like to talk every day.
So once you understand I'm like the morning
radio guy, right? And you're like the weekly
60 Minutes guy, right? And viva la difference,
the problem with events is some people who
are introvert, if they do an event, they need
recovery time.
And so for you to do an event, it should be
you interview somebody on stage, you then
go backstage and write some more notes, and
then somebody else interviews somebody and
then you come back out and do a Q&A with the
audience and then the events over and that's
the totality of the events. I did a bunch
of events because I realized if you could
manifest a community in a real world space,
again, back to my childhood, need to be important
or have power, which was based on having no
power and no money. And I feel like I've kind
of processed that now. I kind of processed
it, if I'm honest, maybe 15, 20 years ago,
I kind of figured it out. But I love the idea
that if you host the party, those people get
to meet new people, create some relationship
or moment that then changes their life forever.
And so what you should be very proud of with
your Open the Kimono event is that to this
day, people talk about it as a peak experience
in their life. And when you think about what
our lives are, in some ways it's just like
Blade Runner when the Nexus-6 is on the roof
and he says like, "Oh, my God, all my memories
are going to be gone like tears in the rain."
All we have at the end of this, I believe,
I'm not a religious guy, I'm an atheist. But
I do know that that singular moment in film
is the most powerful moment in any film I've
ever seen and is kind of my spirit moment
of any piece of cinema or perhaps even literature,
that speech he gives, because that's what
we, I think human existence is about at its
core. It's a series of memories you collect
over time.
You and I playing basketball on that court,
in the woods, in Italy, laughing our asses
off and then you figuring it out, right? It's
just like this weird moment in time that when
I just start describing it to you, you and
I just start laughing where it's just a great
Tim and J Cal moment that nobody else was
there for, is just the two of us literally
in a basketball court hidden in the woods
in on a farm in Italy somewhere that we discovered.
It's a really beautiful memory for me and
I think for you.
Tim Ferriss: And for me too.
Jason Calacanis: And you just, then we'll
get to the end of our lives and just that
Nexus-6 that has this four-year lifespan,
and he's crying for the lost memories. That's
all you have. And then gone like tears in
the rain. So make those memories. And that
Open the Kimono event, I was literally talking
to somebody, not, yeah, I was talking to them
about it on Halloween. It was just two weeks
ago.
Tim Ferriss: Very recent.
Jason Calacanis: And she was describing how
that was her favorite event. I was like, "You've
been to mine?" And she's like, "Yeah, but
that was the one I liked best." And so you
could be proud of, even if that was the only
memory that happened there, that was the only
tear in the rain, you'll always have that,
right? And so for me, that's what it is. People
have these incredible moments and I have them,
and I have now, I'm 51, I'm just looking at
the next number of years we have left. And
people of our age, like Dave Goldberg passed,
Tony Hsieh passed, a lot of our friends are
gone.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it's wild.
Jason Calacanis: Gone too soon. And now I
just look at it, I'm like, "How many more
memories can I put into the memory bank before
the tears in the rain moment?"
Tim Ferriss: So let's talk about friendship,
because there are a few things that come to
mind when I think J Cal and friendship. I
wanted to actually sidestep and just mention
something that ties back to a few things you
said that I was going to bring up later, but
I'm just going to bookmark this one. But this
is a quote from October, 2008 when a lot of
shit was going down. People may or may not
remember, if you weren't aware of it, a lot
of things were imploding. And your quote at
the time in The Guardian is, "Everybody else
is going to be depressed and drinking and
not working, so it's a great time to be an
entrepreneur." So that ties into a lot of
what you already said, but on friends, I want
to say two things related to that. The first
is, let me find this amazing quote. So this
is a quote from Douglas Rushkoff.
Jason Calacanis: Oh, this is a good one. I
put this on the back of my book.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah. "Jason would never
stab you in the back. He might stab you in
the face though." So I really admire you as
a friend. And this is not just for me, this
is related to other people because you are
one of the most loyal friends I have come
across in my adult life, and I've seen you
defend your friends in so many circumstances
where, A, you don't have to out of pure self-interest.
B, there's a very good chance it's never going
to get back to the other person. So I have
a question for you, and maybe that'll be the
first one about loyalty. The second question,
because I do want to talk about All-In, is
going to be how you navigated starting a project
with your very close friends and the conflict
that ensued because I have always avoided
working, by and large, with my friends. So
loyalty, where does that come from and why?
And then the navigating, starting a project
with your close friends.
Jason Calacanis: Well, so much of what makes
us who we are is I think formed in childhood.
So when you're a kid, I think you have this
computer hard drive operating system and things
start getting written to it. And one of the
things that my dad wrote into it is like,
"Hey, you and your brothers, you're The Three
Musketeers. You've got to be there for each
other. Loyalty above everything else. You
always have to have each other's back." And
that wasn't just his operating principle.
It was "You're going to get in a fight on
the way to school. We live in Brooklyn, this
is a dog-eat-dog world. I want to make sure
that you two, you never leave your brothers
behind." So that was one of his rules. If
he saw two of us, he wanted to know, "Where's
your brother? Go get your brother."
Doesn't matter, it's the oldest, the middle,
I'm the middle, or the youngest. You three
have to be by each other's side all the time.
Never leave one of your brothers behind. Never
let anybody say anything to your brother.
Always fight. It was one of the great things
my dad taught me and it stayed with me. And
over time, what I realized was one of my superpowers
is being there for my friends and being a
loyal friend. But I guess the Doug Rushkoff
quote, I might be full contact at times where
if I disagree with somebody —
Tim Ferriss: At times, at times.
Jason Calacanis: At times I might be like,
"I don't agree with you." Or, "That's stupid."
Tim Ferriss: "Timmy, that's the ugliest layup
attempt I've ever seen."
Jason Calacanis: "Jesus, Timmy."
Tim Ferriss: "What the fuck is wrong with
you?"
Jason Calacanis: "What the fuck is wrong with
you? I showed you there's a little square
box there. Just aim for the box. You missed
the entire backboard. There's a little box
behind the rim. Is there's anyway you can
put the ball in the box? Your chances go up
dramatically if you hit that box." You're
like, "Okay, I got it. I'll put it in the
box."
But anyway, I like to laugh. I like to be
loyal. And I think if I have a large number
of acquaintances and then I have a small number
of very close friends, and that seems to me
to be a good philosophy. And then somewhere
along the lines, people become transactional
with you, you've had this experience. We've
talked about it before. Everybody wants something
from Tim Ferriss. Everybody wants Jason to
fix their problems. Or they think they get
a meeting with somebody who's more famous
than the two of us put together, that magically
is going to change their life because they
got to talk to the person and tell them their
ideas.
I'm like, okay, you're delusional. This person
does not care about your ideas and they're
busy. So let Travis finish building Uber,
he doesn't need to talk to you about your
startup. That's not going to make any difference.
And there's something really special about
being able to be supportive of your friends
and being there for them, because as you become
more successful, the world, people think the
world gets bigger. Oh, you have more money.
Oh, your podcast went up the rankings. Oh,
Tim Ferriss is on his 12th best seller. The
world gets smaller and the number of people
—
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it gets a lot smaller.
A lot smaller.
Jason Calacanis: And then you're sitting home
on a Saturday night when you're famous or
affluent or rich or whatever combination of
things you succeeded in your life. And it's
a Saturday night and you're like, going out
to this event is going to be arduous and painful
rather than delightful. And what I realized
is for people who have this in even a more
acute fashion than you or me, you have to
create, I think a safe space. A place where
you can have true friendship and talk about
things that matter. Your kids, your friendships,
your spouses, your life, your hopes, your
dreams, whatever. Or just shoot the shit and
watch a movie and laugh. And so it's kind
of one of the great things in life, I think
is friendships and people. You get what you
put in, you get what — the friendships you
get are the effort you put into the friendships
you have.
And so people don't invest in it. And if people
are so transactional, it's actually kind of
weird. I was at a Halloween party and a lot
of people were coming up to take pictures.
And I don't mind it at all, I'll take a hundred
pictures in a row. It's fantastic. You listen
to the pod, I'm super happy. I suppose for
you it's a little bit annoying, with the extrovert/introvert
thing. I bet you can get through about three
of them before you feel like you need to leave
the party.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, then I need a bathroom
break. I do that at dinners. I mean, I'll
admit something embarrassing, but you won't
be surprised. Maybe people listening will.
If I go to a dinner with or an event with
more than eight or ten people, I will leave
the dinner every 10 minutes to go into the
bathroom and just close my eyes and breathe.
I will disappear. And people are like, "What's
wrong with his prostate?" But it's actually
fine. I'm just so overwhelmed by the stimulation
that I need to take breaks. It's really —
Jason Calacanis: Well. And now imagine it's
people who are a fan of yours or think that
they can use you to achieve some goal, right?
And literally all these influencers, this
party, really their goal is to just get a
picture. And I just had this profound sadness
for them. I'm like, if I was meeting me and
I was an entrepreneur, like a photo's great,
but if you're a first time entrepreneur, maybe
you should ask me about startups and running
them or raising money or there's a million
things we could discuss.
But the goal was to get a selfie? Who cares?
So anyway, it's important to be, I think,
a really good, loyal friend. I have been burned
in this regard where I've been more loyal
to certain people and they have not been loyal
to me. And it's very frustrating for some
of the people around me when they see that
happen to me. And for me, I say that is that
person's chance to learn how to be a friend,
they just haven't gotten there yet. They don't
understand how much more special it would
be if they were reciprocating the friendship
I was showing them. And it makes it just even
more rich. For All-In, it is a very interesting
thing because you and I are solo acts.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: And you have one duet you
do. It's my favorite part of what you do is
—
Tim Ferriss: The Random Show!
Jason Calacanis: With Kevin.
Tim Ferriss: Kevin Rose.
Jason Calacanis: Literally has had profound
impact on my life.
Tim Ferriss: Oh wow.
Jason Calacanis: Big part of why I lost 30
pounds this year. You were telling me how
good I looked, but I was in Italy a couple
of summers ago and you and Kevin were talking
about Ozempic and you had taken Ozempic and
puked and I went to my doctor and I talked
to them about Ozempic, like a TV commercial.
And I haven't talked about this previously,
because I don't want to influence people.
But I did a couple of series of Ozempics along
with fasting that I learned about from you
and Kevin and using the Zero fasting app,
which I learned about from the show. And then
I obviously hear you talk about weightlifting
and the impact that has. And so for the past
year or so, I just did the Tim Ferriss, Kevin
Rose program. I did a couple cycles of Ozempic.
I did the weightlifting and I did the intermittent
fasting using the Zero app. And yeah, I dropped
30 pounds and I —
Tim Ferriss: You look great, man. I said it
before we started recording. I was like, you
look really, really good. Well done.
Jason Calacanis: Would like to get five or
10 more pounds of weight, muscle, and be able
to run a marathon again. So we get those two
goals, I'd be pretty happy.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you can do that. You can
do it You can definitely do it.
Jason Calacanis: I'm in the window.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. So solo act, suddenly decides,
wait a minute, I want to be in a rock band,
but I may —
Jason Calacanis: Did not decide that actually.
I got tricked into it, if I'm being honest.
Tim Ferriss: So tell the story.
Jason Calacanis: Well, no, what happened was
Chamath and I had become friends. Chamath
Palihapitiya.
Tim Ferriss: And you should explain. If people
have no context, what is All-In? What is the
premise?
Jason Calacanis: All-In is a podcast with
four friends who are all capital allocators,
in other words, like, venture capitalist investors
and business builders in — yeah, and I guess
in all cases. And so four folks who are 50
years old, with 30 years of business experience
each, so that's about over 120 years building
businesses or investing in them, getting together
and talking about business, and then whatever
the topics of the day are. But everybody's
a little unique and different. And it started
as something we did in COVID, because we would
all play poker together. And four of the poker
players, eventually, wound up doing this every
week, this podcast, and this is in decade
two of me podcasting. And so I kind of created
a format that I modeled after The McLaughlin
Group, which was a Sunday morning show.
Tim Ferriss: Don't know it.
Jason Calacanis: Yeah. So yeah, there's a
guy, McLaughlin. You can look up some tapes
of it.
Anyway, this guy McLaughlin was super cantankerous
and he'd have a Republican, a Democrat, an
Independent, whatever, a young person, a Bostonian
person, a California hippie, whatever. And
he was always cantankerous and moving the
conversation along and he would say, "Wrong!"
and do this. And it was a very full contact,
kind of dynamic, interrupt each other conversation.
But it always drew me in. It was the best
Sunday morning political show of all time,
The McLaughlin Group.
And so Chamath and I had known each other
from AOL. He was working at AOL when I sold
my company there, the blogging company, back
in the day. We had met. He became a venture
capitalist and then he met Mark Zuckerberg
and he was one of the first employees at Facebook.
Grew Facebook from 10 million to 800 million
users or something crazy like that. He was
responsible for the growth team. Super intelligent,
considerate, fun, thoughtful guy, and dynamic,
aggressive, and just great leader of people.
We became friends, we started playing cards
together, joking, laughing, and I said, "I
really would like to have you on my podcast."
He wanted to be under the radar. He didn't
want people to know who Chamath Palihapitiya
was. But he came on the podcast. In a lot
of ways, like Chris Sacca did, our friend,
I think I was one of the first people to actually
have him on a podcast when I did my two-parter
with him. So Chamath became a bit of a brand
after he was on the podcast a couple times.
And then he keynoted a couple of events and
we just had this rapport. And the rapport
came from just breaking chops and laughing
at the poker game every week. And then people
saw that rapport when we were on stage. And
then he said to me one time when he was coming
out of CNBC, "We should just do a podcast
together."
I was like, "Yeah, come on This Week in Startups."
He said, "No, no, I want to do a different
type of thing, just me and you. You just bring
up the news of the week, I talk about it,
then I ask you a question, and then you talk
about it, and we go back and forth. Startups,
public markets, specs, public private." I
was like, "That's a really good idea. Sure,
let's do it." And we started texting back
and forth and "What do you want to call it?"
And I was like, "We should give, like, a poker
thing since it's like poker. We should call
it All-In." And so the two of us started doing
it, but this was during COVID. So then we're
like, "Well, who knows about COVID?" And Sacks
had been doing a bunch of research on it,
and he bought ventilators and he had masks.
Tim Ferriss: So explain who Sacks is.
Jason Calacanis: So David Sacks is an old
friend of mine who worked at PayPal with Peter
Thiel, went to college with Peter Thiel, is
a Republican, independent, really, chess club,
debate club, brilliant product manager, created
Yammer, sold to Microsoft for a million dollars,
a billion dollars. Just really smart individual,
but right-leaning. Seriously right-leaning,
like writing articles, donating to people
on the right. And we became close friends.
Our families would go on vacation together,
just as close of friends as you could be.
And then we had him on as a guest to talk
about, "Hey, what's going on with this Wuhan
flu thing and what's going on with Trump?"
And people were very scared and confused that
time.
And then we had another friend who came to
poker. I didn't have a big relationship with
Friedberg at the time, I just knew him from
poker. And David Friedberg, who runs something
called the Production Board, he was an early
Google employee, came on and he actually created
climate.com and sold that to Monsanto. So
he understands science at a very deep level.
And so all of a sudden, this thing clicks,
and then Robinhood and that whole AMC thing
happened, and I was an investor in Robinhood,
and we started talking about that. And the
show just caught heat and the dynamic between
the four of us people really started to like,
and people were —
Tim Ferriss: Caught heat in a good way.
Jason Calacanis: I think caught heat in, like,
"Wow, this is really dynamic. They're smart,
they're opinionated, and they're successful."
And so when people see that you've made a
lot of money, is one thing I learned in my
life, it's like the day before the Weblogs,
Inc. sale and then the day after, when I had
no money and then became a millionaire, people
treated me incredibly different. All of a
sudden, I got 30 more IQ points and I was
two feet taller. I was like, I'm the same
guy, but people would just take you a lot
more seriously. And it just is a really good
thing to understand. Literally if you inherited
a billion dollars, people would think you're
a genius. It's a big failing of human nature
that we have this weird thing with the scorecard
that we think the scorecard of dollars is
important. It's not. Long story short, all
the stuff comes together and it seems to connect
with people and it starts racing up the charts.
And the last couple of weeks, I think we're
in number 24, 26, 27, just top 30 podcasts
in the world. Gwyneth Paltrow wrote about
it in her Goop newsletter a couple weeks ago,
that she's obsessed with the podcast, the
personalities. And so This Week in Startups
had millions of listeners every month and
doing incredible, five days a week, making
millions of dollars in advertising. But it's
a very niche thing. It's just about startups.
So if you're in the startup space, you would
want to take a selfie with me. All-In has
crossed over in a way you experience with
the Tim Ferriss Podcast and people who are
pursuing excellence. It's a much wider aperture
of people. And so this thing just appeals
to a lot of people and it's — literally,
people say, it's like their Sunday morning
ritual, or their Saturday morning ritual.
It's replaced the Sunday morning talk show.
And it turns out Politico is writing some
kind of a profile of us right now, because
it's become so influential in Washington,
because we talk about the economy, technology,
and technologies obviously have a big impact
on the economy and politics, whatever. So
anyway, in some ways it's become a hit. It's
very weird for me because I've had a couple
of hits before, but this one also is bigger
and I'm not in control of it.
I have three partners and all three of my
partners on it have never had a boss. So you've
literally got four of the most opinionated
friends who've never had a boss who have four
different directions they want to take it.
And it is a bit chaotic and I'm the producer
of it as well, and did all the work, came
up with the format, et cetera. But objectively,
Chamath has a series of fans. Friedberg has
the stans. Sacks has the whole right wing.
So it's like a super team has come together,
and it's very hard to keep a super team together
for any period of time. And this thing has
come off the rails famously two or three times.
Tim Ferriss: So could you walk us through
your favorite of those three times and how
it was resolved?
Jason Calacanis: Well, I wanted to do an event,
because, you mentioned, bro, I like events,
and I was like, let's do this All-In Summit.
I'll do all the work and you guys show up.
I have a production team and here's what it
will be. And one of the four of us was in
a complete panic and complaining and arguing
incessantly because he thought I was going
to ruin their reputation because what if it's
not great? The thing comes out of the gate,
people are comparing it to the TED Conference,
saying this is better than ReCode, or better
than TED, and it's the new TED, and whatever,
because we got the most incredible speakers
in the world showed up for us, just everybody.
I invited you, you didn't make it, but I'll
get you next year. I don't know if I can afford
your speaking fee, but —
Tim Ferriss: If it makes you feel any better,
I remember this, and I have not done any speaking,
except for South by Southwest, I want to say
in three or four years. But —
Jason Calacanis: There'll be an opportunity.
I'll interview you. No, there'll be some opportunity
where you'll —
Tim Ferriss: And I have —
Jason Calacanis: There will be funding for
us to do it.
Tim Ferriss: And in my own defense, I have
been to events of yours before. I have spoken
with you at events. Yes. So I couldn't make
that one.
Jason Calacanis: Couldn't make that one. Yeah,
it's true.
Tim Ferriss: Anyway, where does the conflict
come in?
Jason Calacanis: So the conflict came in that
I just told him like, "Hey listen, I'm working
over here. "You need to shut the fuck up and
let me just do my work and stop being in a
panic attack all the time." And he's like,
"My reputation. What if it's bad? We pay — people
paid $7,500 a ticket." I'm like, "Listen,
people pay $7,500 a ticket for every event.
It's not a big deal." And then I gave half
the tickets for scholarship for people — anyway,
we had this back and forth, and then I told
the person, I was like, "Friedberg, if you
don't want to be on the show and you're complaining
so much, I got Brad Gerstner over here.
Tim Ferriss: I love how he was anonymous up
until right now.
Jason Calacanis: Whatever. Anyway, the good
news is, Friedberg and I, after this blowout,
like many friendships, we actually are really
enjoying our time together, but it was another
one of these stab you in the back, stab you
in the face things. You know, got the quote
from Doug. I said, "Listen, if you're not
enjoying your time on the All-In podcast and
you don't want to do the event, why don't
you do 25 episodes a year? And I'll have Brad
Gerstner, who sits in when one of us is out,
as like the fifth Beatle, I'll have him do
the other 25." And we got into this big fight
and the whole thing's going to explode and
then these two are going to do their own podcasts,
whatever.
And then we all just sat down and we realized
the audience fucking loves this. We love it.
Let's not do any events. Let's not do any
spin outs. People wanted to do a TV show with
us, top networks, all this stuff. And you
understand how big the podcasting business
now is better than anybody. You've got a top
50 podcast, these podcasts have become a very
big business. On top of that, my biggest media
success to date with my three partners refuse
to do ads.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah. This is one I was
hoping you would bring up. So yeah —
Jason Calacanis: I'm sitting here on arguably
$25 million in advertising, which I would
get 1/4 of. And they're like — Sacks is
like, "Well, I'm already rich and I've got
a plane." And Chamath's like, "Well I got
a plane. I'm already rich. I don't need advertising."
I'm like, "I'll read the ads, I'll sell the
ads." And they're like, "No, it's so cheap
to have an ad." And I'm like, "No, it's not.
It's like everybody's got ads. It's just an
ad. People listen to the ad. They drink some
Athletic Greens. Athletic Greens is healthy
for you. We're done here. Who doesn't love
Athletic Greens?" We're good. Sorry to give
Athletic Greens — use the promo code Tim,
not JCal.
Tim Ferriss: Oh yeah.
Jason Calacanis: Use Tim, not Twist.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I love AG. I was just texting
with the CEO Chris 45 minutes ago.
Jason Calacanis: I just had it this weekend.
I made a really good ginger and some other
juices. I know people drink with water. I
like a little juice. And what I do now is
I use half the amount of Athletic Greens,
but I do it twice a day. I kind of like the
space out Athletic Greens.
Tim Ferriss: I like the ginger idea.
Jason Calacanis: Slightly different. But the
ginger, when you blend that ginger, you have
that spicy. Yum yum.
Tim Ferriss: But your partners were not buying
the ginger cocktail pitch.
Jason Calacanis: So literally, I could use
another $7 million a year. This is big cash,
six or seven million. It's literally to have
—
Tim Ferriss: It's a lot of money.
Jason Calacanis: Well, after taxes, it would
be a jet. I have no jet. This is when this
podcast is — this episode is going to get
clipped like crazy.
Tim Ferriss: So good. This is great.
Jason Calacanis: Let me have a jet. You're
standing between me and private aviation.
I'm being a little facetious right now, but
it's not exactly facetious.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah.
Jason Calacanis: So anyway, I just said, "You
know what? I'm not going to try to monetize
this anymore. We're not going to do live events.
It causes too much chaos. Let's just do it
every week." And then I'm raising my next
venture capital firm, my next venture firm
fund Launch4. And I decided to raise it publicly.
If you pick a designation 506c, you can say
"I'm raising a fund." So I said, "Guys, would
it be okay if on the podcast I mentioned I'm
raising a fund and people can email me jason@calcanis.com."
Boom. All of a sudden, I get a thousand emails.
People are like, "Oh yeah, I'm a rich person.
I would love to be an investor in your fund."
I do five webinars.
Tim Ferriss: I really hope the emails read
exactly that.
Jason Calacanis: Basically. It's like, "Oh
hi, J Cal. I'm a huge fan of All-In. My family
office. We do this, we save the whales, and
we would love — big fancy pod…"
Tim Ferriss: Translation to 140 characters.
"I'm rich. Can you make me richer?"
Jason Calacanis: Basically. And so, I kid
you not, I do five webinars the last five
weeks, $44 million in commitments.
Tim Ferriss: Whoa.
Jason Calacanis: From people I have never
met. My last fund was $44 million. I have
not done an in-person meeting yet. So I said,
you know what? Now listen, for people listening,
in the venture fund, I have to deploy that
money, triple it, and then I get 25 percent
of it. I don't get the 44 million. It's not
a donation. It's what I do for a living. But
holy cow, I was like, I don't need to have
the ads on it. I can just play the long game
and raise a larger venture fund and meet a
bunch more of these LPs or whatever. But every
LP meeting I have, or most meetings I have
now, start with, "Hey, can I take a selfie?
And this is my favorite thing about All-In."
And so it's like I had to come to peace with
the fact, all four of us, that we hit lightning
in a bottle. That's number one. Number two,
we have to trust and love each other and put
on a good show and we have to be rooting for
each other. And I said to everybody, "If we're
going to do this, let's be rooting for each
other." And that means when you're having
this debate and you disagree with me, and
Sacks and I have had blowout battles over
Ukraine, and I'm like, "Listen, Putin needs
to be stopped." And he's like, "Biden and
these people are tempting a nuclear war."
This is a very important debate and it gets
very heated and people think Sacks and I hate
each other. Sacks and I love each other deeply,
even though he can't say it. I can say I love
Sacks and I know he loves me.
And what I hope happened from that podcast
is people see that we can have a brawl, still
love each other, still respect each other,
and still make forward progress and learn
from each other. And Sacks is right about
a lot of the things with Ukraine. We should
have maybe tried for peace earlier. A lot
of the things he said actually turned out
to be right. Now it seems like Biden is saying
to Zelenskyy, "Maybe you guys can start working
on negotiations now and maybe we won't give
you an unlimited supply of support. We're
giving you the weapons. Can you please sit
down and try to work this out?" But it has
created chaos. And because the podcast is
so popular, Tim, it's like a lot of things.
People maybe give it a little too much credit.
Tim Ferriss: Well, yeah, you start to have
a very big responsibility.
Jason Calacanis: Exactly. You nailed it. That's
what I was thinking. Now people are calling
me saying, "Hey, you've got to get Sacks in
line." And then people are calling Sacks saying,
"Oh, J Cal hates Trump. He's got Trump derangements."
I mean, everybody's projecting into this while
we're just having a conversation, like, "Hey,
what gives you the right to have a conversation
about Ukraine? What gives you a right to have
a conversation about affirmative action in
this Harvard case? What gives you the right
to talk about masks and COVID?" And what I
tell people is when we talk about things in
our wheelhouse, capital allocation, company
formation, the markets, take notes. We're
experts. Totally awesome. We've been at it
for over a century combined. Great place for
you to learn if you wanted to be a venture
capitalist entrepreneur or bet on the markets.
Totally get it.
When we talk about anything else, COVID, Ukraine,
politics, we're as informed as you, maybe
a little more, maybe a little less. You're
listening to four people have a conversation.
Go do your own research. Go find your own
truth. And what we found with COVID specifically,
which was kind of ironically where this whole
thing started and what caused it to start
is now Politico, I'm sorry, Vanity Fair and
Politico. No, Vanity Fair and ProPublica,
I don't know if you saw this, are like, "We
intercepted some communications. It looks
like it was probably a lab leak." And we were
sitting here 18 months ago and when different
people in the podcast were saying, "Well,
maybe it's a lab leak," they were like, "Well,
we have to take that podcast down now."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: So we can't have that conversation
that it's a lab leak?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: There's two labs in the world
that are studying the Wuhan virus and one
of them is where the leak happened. I mean,
one of them, when COVID happened, it happens
to be in Wuhan. There's 10,000 locations in
the world. Pretty easy jump to make, but there's
some weird thing going on right now where
people expect Tim Ferriss or Joe Rogan or
David Sacks can't have a conversation and
talk about a topic, because their shows are
popular. And we have to work this out, because
you are allowed to have a conversation and
people need to come to their own truth. And
sometimes institutions do a great job, sometimes
they fail us. We still have to debate these
issues.
Tim Ferriss: If it's helpful. I can tell you
my policy on this stuff.
Jason Calacanis: Please, tell me.
Tim Ferriss: Or I should say my protocol.
My protocol is if I'm going to talk about
something that I know is going to light people
up, but that it is important and I feel like
I have maybe access to an expert who can actually
speak credibly, then I'll add in very strong
disclaimers and then I will not look at Twitter
for at least a week.
Jason Calacanis: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: It's very simple. It's like,
it's very simple. It's like if you don't want
the cock punches, don't go to where everyone's
throwing cock punches.
Jason Calacanis: You'll get Ouch My Balls.
Literally Idiocracy, the TV show, Ouch My
Balls. You're going to get your nuts kicked
over and over and over again just for having
a conversation. I thought Joe Rogan did a
really good job when they were like, "Hey,
you're having these people on, they have uncertain
whatever." And he's like, "I'm a comedian."
And I'm like, "Yeah, you're a comedian with
10 million or 20 million viewers." And he's
like, "You know what, if I get it wrong, tell
me who to have on. I'll do it again. But again,
I'm a comedian, interviewing people and trying
to learn." And I actually think there's a
little bit of responsibility on the audience's
part here.
Tim Ferriss: There is. I will —
Jason Calacanis: You know he's a comedian.
Tim Ferriss: There is. However, I'm going
to push back a little bit.
Jason Calacanis: Okay, yeah, let's go.
Tim Ferriss: And just that — to just say
that I have, I, well, decline or, through
vetting, disqualify probably 80 percent of
the people that might be on the show, because
I do a lot of fact checking ahead of time
and I will do scientific fact checking, reference
checking. And if it seems like someone is
playing it too fast and loose, they do not
come on the show, generally speaking. So I
do a lot of heavy lifting on the front end,
which if someone's goal is to learn and they're
not a domain expert, I think is incumbent
upon them, if they have a large audience,
and I'm not saying Joe doesn't do that, but
I do think —
Jason Calacanis: Well he said he doesn't do
it. He said, "I don't come prepared."
Tim Ferriss: Oh, there you go.
Jason Calacanis: "Just to be clear, when this
whole thing blew up, I want to let you know
I do not come in prepared. Sometimes I just
have — somebody hands me notes." He said,
"And I'm thinking about changing that." So
I do think if he's going to talk about medical
stuff, he should have a researcher do some
stuff. And then I also —
Tim Ferriss: You're a very close friend of
mine and, like —
Jason Calacanis: Yeah, look. Yeah, I know
you do research.
Tim Ferriss: I've got 20 pages of notes.
Jason Calacanis: Which is why, when you talk
about whatever topic you're talking about,
the audience has an expectation that it's
going to be tight. When people go into Joe
Rogan, they should have the expectation that
he just walked in unprepared or modestly prepared.
So that's where I think —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: Audiences have to take some
responsibility. It's probably between the
two things we're talking about.
Tim Ferriss: It's between the two. And I think
that, and he might not want to do this, but
if Joe wanted to do something preemptively,
it's just at the very heading of the show,
there could be a disclaimer of the kind of
disclaimer you'd see on Jackass back in the
day, which would be like, "These are professionals,
this is for entertainment, and do your own
homework."
Jason Calacanis: It's a little bit of a tell
that we're doing stupid things that we will
regret. Actually I have an idea for Joe Rogan.
I think he should start a second podcast,
it'll make tens of millions of dollars, called
After Joe. And it should be a group of experts
vetting whatever was talked about or goofing
on it.
Tim Ferriss: That's a great idea.
Jason Calacanis: And After Joe, Post Joe,
and it would just be a breakdown of what happened
on the episode and then he could say, "Listen.
Yeah. Did you listen to After Joe or Post
Joe? Post Joe wrote a webpage." Like you do
great notes and there's people who do show
notes of both of our shows once in a while
that are pretty good. He should just pay somebody
a thousand bucks to do a show notes. The thing
makes so much money. Pay three people $2,000
each. You spend five grand on it. This is
a medical episode. Vet it, put a bunch of
links in it. That would just make it so much
better, right? I think.
Tim Ferriss: So I have a question.
Jason Calacanis: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: Since I did call you Podcast
Master in the beginning, and I want to put
on a showcase for a moment. So you and I have
offline talked, well I guess it's probably
online, but offline meaning not publicly,
talked about how you prepare privately. Jesus,
what am I, a writer? I used to be. Use your
words, Ferriss. Privately.
Jason Calacanis: You're a great writer.
Tim Ferriss: You've talked about your moderating.
I think you are one of the best moderators
I've ever seen.
Jason Calacanis: Aww.
Tim Ferriss: And it's true. That is absolutely
— I would say that to anyone. I think I'm
actually pretty sure I have said it publicly.
Jason Calacanis: You have, actually. Thank
you for that.
Tim Ferriss: And I'd like to look at the mechanics
and the preparation that goes into that, because
you've talked to me about this and I remember
one of the examples again, which is hyper-specific,
which is, if you guys are on Zoom, which most
people are not going to see, raising your
hand and using visual cues for things. So
could you walk through what the preparation
process looks like for a good episode?
Jason Calacanis: So we build a docket every
week for All-In. The docket I took from Red
Scare, which is this dirtbag left podcast,
these two women who live in the Dimes Square
in New York. They're quite charming and hilarious,
probably a little cutting edge for some people.
But anyway, the Red Scare podcast is hilarious
and Dasha always says, "Oh, what's on the
docket?" And they have a docket. These are
the people who we're going to pass judgment
on before a judge. So we have a docket. I
make a docket every week with my producer,
Nick. And basically we're in a group chat
and whatever links we share that week, we
put in there. And then with the docket —
Tim Ferriss: So the docket is a Google Doc?
Jason Calacanis: Google Doc of topics.
Tim Ferriss: And then this is put into a private
Slack channel that you guys use or something
like that?
Jason Calacanis: Yeah. We're on Signal and
so we —
Tim Ferriss: Signal. Great.
Jason Calacanis: Yeah, so they all disappear
within a week. Hard lessons to learn. Thank
you for getting it. So anyway, Signal. You
can reach me on Signal.
Tim Ferriss: So now do you use desktop client
for that to make it easier to use or do you
do it all on mobile?
Jason Calacanis: Yeah. Signal is desktop and
mobile now. Yeah, it's pretty great. And it's
not owned by the Russians.
Tim Ferriss: Do you use mobile?
Jason Calacanis: I use mobile and I use the
desktop, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, great.
Jason Calacanis: Yeah. And anyway, I have
the bullet points in there, and I will sometimes
push people to come up with topics. So hey,
when Friedberg was kind of sitting back a
lot on the episodes, I kind of dubbed him
the Sultan of Science and I kind of created
this character and I said, "Listen, you're
kind of like a little bit of a wallflower
last episode. Can you give me whatever the
most interesting science story of the week
is?" And if I don't get one by whatever, a
day before taping, I'm like, "Hey," and maybe
I'll do a little research myself. "Hey, what
do you think of this? Or what about that?"
And when I get a science topic out of him,
I throw to him and he just lights up. It's
great.
And then Chamath will make a joke or Sacks
will go check his email. And then for Sacks,
I throw him red meat. So the red meat for
Sacks is anything political, anything to do
with the Constitution, anything to do with
the Supreme Court or legal cases. And then
if I want to give an alley-oop to Chamath,
so I think about it as the moderator. I've
got to get out of this guy, I've got to get
him engaged, Friedberg. I've got to give him
some science so that he gets excited, right?
Because he's not excited to talk about politics,
because he doesn't like it. With Sacks, I've
got a tiger, like a fierce tiger. And if I
throw a couple of chickens out there, he's
going to maul them. But I know what they are.
So I'm like, "Okay, here you go. Supreme Court
decision." Loses his mind.
"Oh, here you go. Biden said this and it's
inconsistent." Or boom, "Hey, here's something
with Trump." He's going to just go crazy.
So now you got your lion going crazy. You
got your science nerd coming out of his shell.
And then with Chamath, it's more like an alley-oop.
Tim Ferriss: Sweaters.
Jason Calacanis: I know — what's that?
Jason Calacanis: Loro Piana. Conspicuous consumption.
No, it really is more about markets and startups.
And for him, I like to say to him, "Can you
explain this financial topic and why people
are talking about interest rates are bad for
tech companies? Why would the interest rate
have any impact on that?" Now I know the answer
to that, but he can actually explain it better
than anybody on the squad. So what I'm doing
there as the point guard is like I have a
clear path to the basket, I can just lay it
in and do the layup, but I see him out the
corner of my eye, and I'm like, you know what
a big the audience have a better experience,
is if I pretend I'm going to do the layup,
and then from behind my back, I throw it up
to him and he slam dunks it.
And so I've learned with each of them how
to feature them and make them really their
best selves. And then behind the scenes, when
you see the point guard in basketball take
somebody and they whisper in their ear something,
I very quietly give them notes on their performance,
on how to do that —
Tim Ferriss: And this is after each episode?
Jason Calacanis: After each show. Oh, I did
it had to do it more earlier. And then sometimes
I'll do it in the group chat, if I think it's
something everybody can benefit from. But
more often than not, I'm doing it quietly.
And so I had to say to Friedberg, "Listen,
you know, don't say a lot about politics,
but I think your opinion actually represents
a large portion of the audience. And although
you hate it, I think you expressing a little
bit is going to be fine. And if you're not
happy with how it comes out, and I think it's
putting you at risk, I will tell you, and
we can cut it from the show." And once I gave
him that, sort of, I think a little bit of
a clear lane and encouragement, you will hear
him talk a little bit more about politics,
not to the extent Sacks does. And then I had
to tell Sacks, "Hey Sacks, when I ask you
something or I challenge you, I'm not disagreeing
with you. I'm helping you clarify your position
or helping the audience understand your position
more."
Tim Ferriss: Very, very smart way to put it.
Jason Calacanis: "And you are attacking me,
telling me I'm watching MSNBC and I get my
information from Rachel Maddow. I didn't ask
you to explain…" One time, I said, "Just
to be clear, Putin invaded Ukraine, not Biden.
Correct?" And he just went off or whatever.
And I said, "The reason I'm asking you that
is because the audience thinks, and the feedback
online is, you're a Putin apologist. It would
help your position if you said to the audience,
'Putin and Putin alone is responsible for
invading Ukraine.' Now how we manage Putin
and his unjust immoral invasion is up to us.
And that's what we can debate." But I'm trying
to save him from being misunderstood.
Tim Ferriss: And so you're like one part moderator,
one part coach, one part comms director.
Jason Calacanis: Well, in a way —
Tim Ferriss: I'm not saying that as a bad
thing. It's just like —
Jason Calacanis: No, no, no, I think it's
super active.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you're helping everybody.
Jason Calacanis: Well what I realized was
like — listen, you and I have done hundreds
of interviews with people. Great. It's awesome.
We're both interested in people and learning
from them and having great conversations.
But this became something different for me,
being the orchestrator of the action.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, it's a different skill, different
skill.
Jason Calacanis: It was a totally different
skill. And I had done these moderations before
at events, and I had sometimes done round
tables, news round tables, but a lot of times,
I was one of the featured players, not the
point guard.
Tim Ferriss: Can I give one example of why
they're totally different? In a one-on-one
conversation, you can have a guest who monologues.
If you have a group of people, that can be
a huge problem. How do you deal with that
specifically?
Jason Calacanis: There's two techniques. Yeah,
two techniques, because you and I like technique.
So the two techniques I have. One of them
is I say to people beforehand, "Great job
on the show today. At this moment in time,
you made four really great points. It would've
been better if you made your first one or
two and then said, 'I'm really interested
in what Sacks thinks of that.' Or 'I'm curious,
Sacks, what you think?' And then you have
those two. Just write them on a piece of paper
there. There'll be time for those two. We'll
circle back around. But now it doesn't look
like you are taking all the chips off the
table." Because in a conversation, with four
smart people about a topic, there might be
five good points to make. All four people
might understand all five points or four of
the points. And then if somebody comes in
and they're just like, ding, ding, ding, ding,
I just took all the good points, there's nothing
left for anybody else to do.
And so you want to share the ball a little
bit. You took two good points. You let somebody
else make a good point. You could have made
that point. It was an obvious one, but you
let somebody else have it. It's a little bit
generous as a performer. So it'd be like,
you know, you've got some incredible guitar
player. They come out and they just do a solo
of six minutes and you're like, "Piano guy
could have done a solo for a minute. You could
have done two. We could've given the drummer
a minute and they could've let the vocalist
lead off the song with an a capella moment,
right?" And so I've really tried to be better
at it and specifically tried to be better
at it, because people have been critical of
me for interrupting certain people. And so
I had to actually adapt to that. And so, because
certain people, if you interrupt them, it's
a trigger for them or it can break their train
of thought.
Tim Ferriss: And I ran into this —
Jason Calacanis: That's where I came up with
—
Tim Ferriss: I ran into this recently and
I was like, I wondered, "How would Jason handle
this?" I was curious.
Jason Calacanis: So I came up with another
one. I said, "I'm going to give you the circle."
So if people aren't watching right now, I'm
just taking my index finger, and I'm just
given the wrap up sign. But I'm also nodding.
So I'm saying, "Yeah, good stuff. I'm giving
you the good stuff. But hey, let's wrap that
point." And then I'll just stop and they finish
their thought. And the other thing I do is
I just use, "Okay." And I got that from Sam
Harris. I was listening to Sam's podcast.
He gets people monologuing. These are some
of the most brilliant academics in the world
on his show. And you'll see sometimes he wants
to break in, but I think in academia, it's
even more difficult to do that.
Tim Ferriss: Verboten. Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: Verboten. That's the word
I was looking for. My dyslexia was killing
me on that one. Forberwritten? Verboten. You
let people finish, but he'll say, "Okay."
And it's like, "Okay, I got it. Okay, you
did it." And then the person's like, "Oh,
oh, Sam has something to add." And that's
in a one on one situation. You get good by
studying. I study a lot of what you do and
you have a way when you're asking a question
of slowing down and it's almost as if you're
bringing us into your brain for the formation
of the question. And that was me imitating
you.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: But, yeah. You do it, it's
like somebody at a dinner party who's talking
in a lower voice and everybody leans in. I
know it's going to be a fucking important
question when you do that, and I don't know
if it's unconscious or it's conscious or you
are truly forming the question. But when listening
to Tim Ferriss, when Tim slows down and Tim
is thinking, "I want to ask you one more question.
I have it on this note here. Hold on…" It
means it's a really important question and
it really does work as a technique and everybody's
techniques doesn't have to work for everybody.
Like I talk fast. You talk a little slower,
more methodically. Sam talks even more monotone.
Tim Ferriss: He speaks in finished prose.
Jason Calacanis: Unless it's about Trump,
then he gets on tilt. It is funny how we all
study each other, right?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah, I love doing it. I
mean, I remember doing so much studying in
the beginning. I'm still studying.
Jason Calacanis: Me too.
Tim Ferriss: It's fun to notice, because when
you're in the game and you're doing a lot
of interviewing, I don't do as much moderating,
so I can't speak to that, but you begin to
notice, just like you noticed, you begin to
notice the little things that were you not
also doing a lot of reps you wouldn't pick
up.
Jason Calacanis: It's about the reps.
Tim Ferriss: I wanted to ask you about moderators.
You mentioned The McLaughlin Group earlier.
Are there any that stand out as good moderators
to you?
Jason Calacanis: There's not a big cohort
of moderators, because almost everything is
— yeah. I mean, you might say, what's his
name from Politically Incorrect?
Tim Ferriss: Bill Maher?
Jason Calacanis: Bill Maher. So Bill Maher,
he can drop something funny into a moderated
bit. So two people are talking and I do a
little comedy on the side and will sometimes
make jokes during the podcast. And I have
seen him do this particularly well. He's watching
two people spar and he's kind of set that
up and he's leaning back and then he just
lets a little funny thing out.
So as a device for a moderator, it's getting
super heated and then you drop something funny
and you'll see me do this on all end. It kind
of just cracks the whole thing open. Everybody's
like, okay, that was getting really serious,
but we're all humans and we can laugh too
about it. So somebody's having some crazy
debate about Roe v. Wade and then he makes
some joke and you're just like, whoa, that's
a funny joke. Oh, I can laugh about Roe v.
Wade and abortion? Oh my god, I'm not allowed
to laugh about that. That's a dicey place
to be, but that comedic interruption, it works
pretty well, but there aren't many people
or shows that do it well.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: I think you could pull it
off, I think with, you have your great rapport
with Kevin Rose and if you've got one or two
more you could do your own little All-In/McLaughlin
Group thing, it would be quite successful,
I think.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I guess it comes down to
the chemistry, like you said, because with
Kevin it's like we just, it's having a good
improv comedy partner or something. It's like
your styles just work for some reason and
then you can always improve the craft and
work on it. But there is just this baseline
of compatible chemistry.
Jason Calacanis: When you look at your podcast
player. If I see Random Show, that's just
like, I snap that immediately, when The Random
Show comes up in my feed. Because you know
what? We were going back to friendship. We
spent a little time in this conversation.
Friendship is so special. It is one of those
very special things in the world's unique.
And when people see friendship, true friendship,
it's such an intoxicating thing to know that
you and Kevin are having a great time catching
up and we get to be there for it.
And I do think that is a big part of why people
have become addicted to All-In. And we had
one or two weeks we took off and man, I have
never had people, I was so depressed. "God,
what's going on?" And then when the show was
going to break up, and "Oh, my god, what's
going on? This sucks, man." People wrote me
very long notes. "I really think you guys
need to think about the fans and the impact
is going to have on us." And I feel like we're
in Pink Floyd and Roger Waters and Gilmore
are doing separate tours and they're like,
"It's the same songs, folks. You could just
listen to the old albums."
Tim Ferriss: I think there's another piece
which is right parallel to this, and that
is with friendship on display, you get to
hear people also talking as humans without
overly self censoring in a world where that
has become the norm. Do you know what I mean?
Jason Calacanis: Yeah, no, just now in our
conversation, when we were bringing up "Ouch!
My Balls!" from Idiocracy, I was like, "Oh,
we're going there? Oh, no. Are we going to
get canceled for liking a funny bit in the
movie?"
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. And the fact of the matter
is as, I don't think anyone will disagree.
If anyone listening to this podcast had their
group chats publicly shared, everything would
be over. It's just like their chats with their
five closest friends. All of us would be unmasked
for the complete children that we all are.
Jason Calacanis: Yes. Goofballs.
Tim Ferriss: And despite that, given the times,
I think the majority of folks feel like they
have to put on a mask and stuff all of that
so far down, because the risk seems so high.
So when you have a show where friends are
having fun, they're not taking themselves
or anything too seriously, even though they
do take things seriously in life. It allows
everyone to just exhale for a second.
Jason Calacanis: Yeah. Chill out.
Tim Ferriss: Take off the psychological corset
that they strain to put on in the morning.
Jason Calacanis: It is very weird being a
Gen Xer where the Overton window was so much
wider when we were young and now the Overton
window, people are like, close it tighter,
close it tighter. And I'm like, who cares?
Just a window. You can pick how wide or open
you want it to be, but people are really trying
to narrow the topics you can discuss in a
way that I find kind of a bummer, because
all those conversations are still going to
occur. They're just going to occur in private.
I almost would rather they be occurring publicly
so we could make more progress as a society.
It feels like —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. I agree.
Jason Calacanis: It feels like it's going
to work against us. I hope it opens up. That's
why I was talking about that Red Scare podcast
or another podcast. I like is the guy who
wrote Less Than Zero and American Psycho,
Bret Easton Ellis.
Tim Ferriss: Oh yeah.
Jason Calacanis: And both of these are on
Patreon and both of these are behind paywalls,
which I think is interesting. Both of them
are podcasts where people are being an Overton
window that's twice as wide open.
Tim Ferriss: But just for folks who are listening:
Overton window?
Jason Calacanis: What's allowable to discuss
in society writ large. I'm using a fancy word.
What you're allowed to talk about in society
without feeling ashamed or that you are being
inappropriate. So there was a time —
Tim Ferriss: Or you're going to be persecuted.
Jason Calacanis: Persecuted for sure. So there
was a time when just even talking about somebody
being a homosexual was outside the Overton
window. And if you brought it up, everybody
would leave the dinner party, be aghast. "Oh,
my God." So you had to just treat a person
who was a gay person at a dinner party as
like, "Oh, yes, they've got a roommate," and
we're just going to sweep that under the rug.
"Oh, yeah, they're here with their roommate.
They split their rent, because it's cheaper."
And then you could be like, "Yeah, Ernie and
Bert are gay. They're roommates. Pretty obvious."
Tim Ferriss: I like the little judo move you
did with the Ernie and Bert there, the jelly
and peanut butter. I was like, "Well, wait
a second. Oh, wow." I'm just, "Now I know."
Yeah. I like it. I like it.
Jason Calacanis: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So you have this experience with
these friends, you build this podcast. Two
questions that you can pick, either or both.
The first is, you mentioned capturing lightning
in a bottle. And I'd be curious how you would
explain the success of this show, because
there must be, you were so deliberate, so
deliberate. Every example you've given, I
think from at least your earlier career, shows
how systematic and methodical you are. So
I know it wasn't an accident. It may have
coalesced in a way that couldn't have been
predicted, but I don't think it was an accident.
So how would you explain the popularity? What
are the ingredients?
Jason Calacanis: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And then secondly, how do you
now think about success for yourself? And
you made that joke earlier about being separated
from the private jet, your friends standing
in the way of this private jet. So I was just
curious —
Jason Calacanis: Jet blockers.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. How do you think about
success and or power? Because that played
such a role in your life up to this point.
So the ingredients that made the podcast successful
or that make it successful, and then the success
power piece.
Jason Calacanis: I think there is something
that comes from repetition and getting reps
in, and you and I are both big fans of that.
And so I think having done whatever at the
time, maybe 13- or 1,400 episodes of This
Week in Startups and all those event interviews,
I came into All-In with a 10-person podcasting
team. I mean, that includes some salespeople,
so whatever. But having had done so many podcasts
that I came in with so much knowledge and
ability and it was like, oh, my skill, but
a different playing field.
It would be like somebody who plays ping pong
all of a sudden gets on a tennis court, which
happened to me. I used to play ping pong as
a kid and I bought a house that has a tennis
court, quite embarrassingly. It's a mind-blowing
thing for a kid from Brooklyn to have a tennis
court on their property. You're like, "Wait,
aren't there two for 10,000 people in Brooklyn?
And you have to wait to get on it." And then
I have one, where I can just sit there and
let it go unused for a month. Like ping pong
and tennis is the same thing. There's a net,
there's a ball, you put spin on it. And I
started taking tennis lessons this year and
it was like, woo, your brain kind of lights
up?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: Same thing, but different
game skill. So I think it was all that preparation
had led to this new thing that you actually
cued off on and we talked about last year
for an hour during the winter of, "Hey, what
happened there?" And so I think that was the
lightning in the bottle for me personally,
was maybe I'm a better moderator than an interviewer.
Maybe that actually was sitting there the
whole time. Maybe I'm a better tennis player
than a ping pong player.
So that for me, I think has opened up a lot
of possibility, possibilities of what I could
do with the last 10, 20, 30, 40 years, whatever
I've got left on this planet, before the tears
in the rain moment happens. And so it has
opened my aperture a bit and I am thinking
about things differently, which dovetails
with your second question, which is, after
I made whatever amount of millions of dollars,
I had a profound realization when I go out
to eat with a friend who's a billionaire of
me, you, and Travis were sitting around, or
me, you, and Matt Mullenweg were sitting around
and we took out our net worths and was like,
"Oh, my God, you and I are down here. These
two guys are up here."
We all go and have a steak. Steak tastes the
same, we all go and go skiing or we go to
Japan. Same experience. And once I realized
that, I was like, for me, it might be different
for other people, the scorecard of cash doesn't
matter beyond a certain point. And for me
it was the freedom to do whatever I want in
my life and to take care of my three daughters,
take care of my wife, and be a good provider,
take care of my extended family if they needed
some help on the margins.
And once that happened, I was like, I actually,
I drive a Model Y and I prefer that to the
Plaid. And I have a Model X, I enjoy sometimes
the New York strip better than Wagyu. I just
kind of like the flavor of it. It's a fifth
of the price.
So once you start to realize, okay, these
are just constructs and money is just not
the right scorecard. The right scorecard is,
did you wake up and couldn't wait to get out
of bed. To me, that's the true scorecard.
I cannot wait to get on air and do this weekend
startups with Molly and talk about tech. Can't
wait to meet with founders. I can't wait to
teach another course on how to start a company.
Can't wait to see my friends for dinner, can't
wait to help my friends if they're in need.
Can't wait to come on the Tim Ferriss pod.
If I can't wait to do the activity, I know
I'm doing something right. When you invited
me on, I went to Jade, I was like, my wife's
name is Jade, and I was like, "Oh, Tim invited
me on the podcast. I can't wait to do it."
And I have never, that very rarely happens,
but I was like, "I listen to the Tim Ferriss
podcasts all the time, and I'm sure at some
point I'll be on it." But the act of doing
it with you, to me was like, "Oh, I'm excited."
And being excited and enthusiastic, to me,
it just means something has aligned. And when
I'm writing, you and I have the same thing,
when you get, I don't know where it is for
you, but somewhere around a third of the book,
things start heating up for me and all of
a sudden the first third of the book is like,
"Oh." And then all of a sudden, "Oh, I know
what sections I have to do. I can see behind
the next corner, the book just flows." And
you're like, "Boom," 2,000 words are coming
out at a clip.
And those kind of moments, when you have that
flow and you have that enthusiasm for life,
you have to construct a life around those.
And then life is just pulling you out of bed
every day and just telling you, I got to go
to bed every night. I go to bed. And I'm just
like, I don't want to close my eyes. I want
to just do another hour. And it's hard for
me to go to bed some nights, because my enthusiasm
is so high for life and I wasn't always that
way. A lot of it was a struggle. A lot of
it was trying to figure out who I was.
But I really do want to enjoy this last couple
of decades of if there's an interesting project
or moment that's going to create that great
memory and going to make me enthusiastic,
I want to do it. And if that means helping
out a friend on a special project or going
on a friend's podcast or whatever, doing a
new podcast. I feel very blessed that I got
here and I want to just squeeze every single
drop of juice out of that box of oranges.
I mean, really think about it, our friend
Dave Goldberg, rest in peace, Tony Hsieh,
the darkness there, it can be over and it
can be, it's exactly like our age range where
we start saying goodbye to people. And so
if you are in your 20s or 30s, you're just
on adrenaline and then you get to 40s and
50s and you're like, "Huh, what do I do with
what's left?" Especially if some things have
hit for you. If you're Tim Ferriss, you've
got to really start thinking, "Okay, well
I'm one of the top podcasters in the world,
one of the top authors in the world, is this
actually making me happy?"
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: And that's the thing I'm
writing in my new book about is, my new book
is about money and wealth and I really —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I can't wait to read it.
Jason Calacanis: Can't wait, well I want to
send you some early stuff and get your thoughts
on it, but I'm writing about this paradox
that you and I are talking about right now,
which is what happens when you catch the car?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: What happens? It's part,
how do you catch the car? But then once I
get you on the hook for that, how do you get
the money? Now what happens when you have
caught the car? And then now you have to look
in the mirror, "I caught the car. Okay, the
adrenaline rush is over. Am I actually happy?
Did I want to catch that car? Did I want to
be Tim Ferriss? Did I want to be J Cal? Did
I want to be Travis? Did I want to be Matt
Mullenweg?"
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: "Is this actually making
me happy? What now?" And that's where Buddhism
and a lot of soulfulness has hit me in my
50s or right before my 40s, basically when
my two friends died. Two of my poker buddies
died and it just reprogrammed my brain in
a major way, those two events. And it's actually
been a gift in a way, because now I just look
at the world differently. It's a big —
Tim Ferriss: Put things in perspective.
Jason Calacanis: Yeah. I mean it does really.
Tim Ferriss: And another pattern I've noticed,
just with respect to catching the car, is
that not everyone, but a lot of achievers
I know who have been driven enough off and
worked hard enough and focused long enough
and sacrificed enough to make a lot of money,
when they finally crossed that threshold where
they can't really rationalize the need to
make more, which by the way, I mean, not to
plug my own, I haven't done this, I haven't
mentioned The 4-Hour Workweek in a long time,
but if you actually read some of the basics,
the fundamentals in that book, it outlines
just how much self-deception goes into believing
that you need 20, 30, 50, a 100 million dollars.
It's mostly unjustifiable.
Jason Calacanis: Totally.
Tim Ferriss: And when you get enough money
that you've won the game, you always thought
would answer your prayers and remove all the
pain, anxiety, and depression, and it doesn't,
that is a terrifying moment.
Jason Calacanis: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, my God, do people — and
I'll include myself in this group of people
—
Jason Calacanis: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: — begin to panic, because you're
like, "Wait a second, if that didn't fix these
things…"
Jason Calacanis: Yep. "What will?"
Tim Ferriss: "What in the fuck am I supposed
to do?" And it can be, and I don't want to
make it a complete swan song. I mean, look,
it's better to — all things being equal
— to have the money than to not have the
money. However, the prevalence of depression
in successful people, that has increased,
rather than decreased, after they catch the
car, it's worth studying. I think it tells
us a lot about the human condition, even if
you never end up catching the car.
Jason Calacanis: And this is where doing the
work internally, and I really respect the
fact that you've used some of the resources
you've gathered to do the work you're doing
at psychedelics.
Tim Ferriss: Thank you.
Jason Calacanis: I've never publicly talked
about the psychedelic work or psychedelics
period, because as a person who sometimes
people follow what I do with a fan base — I
talked about actually taking Ozempic for the
first time. I think there's suffering in the
world that psychedelics are uniquely qualified,
I suspect. And you'd want to talk to a doctor
and a therapist and do these things in a very
considered fashion. But the fact that you
are looking at psilocybin and other people
are looking at ayahuasca or ketamine or whatever,
I think the research and the suffering that's
happening, a lot of it is because people have
not done enough of the work to look inside
and find out where that trauma is and maybe
try and clear it and maybe try to understand
it. And that is, I think, the breakthrough
that's going to happen in our lifetime, because
of people like you and some other friends
of ours, who have dedicated significant resources
towards the study of these. I don't know if
you saw Colorado? I think past —
Tim Ferriss: I did, yeah.
Jason Calacanis: 122 yesterday.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. It's big news. Very big
news.
Jason Calacanis: It's big news. Colorado's
going to allow therapists to do all these
different psychedelics in really safe settings
with really qualified people for people who
have PTSD, people who have trauma, people
who have anxiety, people who've been to wars,
people whose lives have been wars, and it's
having a profound impact. And people are out
there and they're suffering.
I really, really encourage them to go to therapy
and to maybe even research this stuff, because
again, you give these disclaimers all the
time on this podcast, but there is help out
there and you don't need to suffer alone.
And sometimes people will mask their suffering
and mask their problems with performance.
And this is the show about performance and
that's why people listen to it and people
are drawn to it. But sometimes we're drawn
to performance, because we don't want to face
the pain or suffering that is driving that
performance. The fuel, a lot of times those
hot coals that are burning, that's a lot of
pain and suffering and it fuels an engine,
a mighty engine. But then you get to the destination
we're talking about here and then, hey, maybe
this isn't serving me well anymore. And you
want it to serve you well.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, agreed. And I'll make just
a couple recommendations for folks. One, this
is an extremely heavy podcast in terms of
content, but if people are curious in the
capacity of researching psychedelic therapies
or psychedelic assisted therapies, but also
looking at alternatives to that, I did do
a podcast that people can find at tim.blog/trauma,
which is a conversation between myself and
Debbie Millman.
Jason Calacanis: That's incredible.
Tim Ferriss: Who suffered from a horrible
childhood abuse. And we took very different
paths, but found solace, found support in
very, very different ways. And there are a
lot of resources associated with the blog
post and the show notes that people can look
at the other, if people are interested in
identifying at least some of the credible
institutions and scientists doing research
on, say, complex PTSD and MDMA-assisted psychotherapy,
which is now, I believe, through phase three
and psilocybin for treatment-resistant depression,
et cetera. If you go to saiseifoundation.org,
that's the foundation I started some time
ago, which is S, A, I, S, E, I, which means
"rebirth" in Japanese, saiseifoundation.org.
There's a projects page where you can see
the various universities and a lot of the
researchers.
Jason Calacanis: I've been looking for this
to see where all the research is actually
occurring. You actually made a page. I was
telling somebody recently, there should just
be a place people could go to see where the
progress has been, because people are not
aware of how much people, I think it's next
year that MDMA will be available in therapy
in some psychiatric settings, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I'd have to check the latest
and greatest. It's certainly last time I checked
in, it would be as potentially as soon as
the end of, say, 2023 or early 2024. I'll
have to check. There's so much flux, because
there's not only the federal landscape and
potential reclassification, which you can
do through demonstrating medical need. Because
schedule one is supposed to be, and I'm painting
with a very simplistic brush here, but schedule
one compounds are supposed to be drugs with
a high potential for abuse that have no known
medical application. And rather than fighting
the political fight, which you do have to
fight at some point, you can demonstrate medical
application through good science and clinical
trials, which has been the area where I've
predominantly focused. But then you have Colorado,
you have Oregon as well. And these parallel
systems or initiatives to create parallel
systems on a state basis, a statewide basis,
that will be very interesting experiments.
And they could go a lot of different ways.
I mean, it could all go well. There will probably
be, as happens when therapies scale, various
issues and problems and scandals and so on.
I expect that. Humans are humans, so they're
going to find a way to screw it up one way
or the other, but net the hope, and I do think
there's a lot of good that has come of, say,
the decriminalization nature initiatives,
although I disagree with some of their stances.
It's a very exciting time of flux at the moment.
And as you put it, there is help out there
and there are sources.
Jason Calacanis: If you think about what we
saw happen with cannabis in this country and
the legalization of it, life went on. But
these drugs are really going to help people,
I think, especially with the complex PTSD,
especially with anxiety.
Tim Ferriss: Absolutely.
Jason Calacanis: It's just great when combined
with a proper therapist, I think.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, they're very powerful,
as a friend of mine, I don't think he said
it publicly, so I'll keep it anonymous, but
a very senior scientist. He said when you're
working with psychedelic compounds, you are
working with nuclear power, so you just need
have the right therapeutic context around
it. But they're very, very, very powerful.
J Cal?
Jason Calacanis: Yeah?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. We're coming up on —
Jason Calacanis: I was like, oh wow. Just
a quick 75 minutes, 90 minutes. I looked at
two hours.
Tim Ferriss: Two hours.
Jason Calacanis: We talked two hours.
Tim Ferriss: Two hours plus. Is there anything
that you would put just as winding this to
close? Anything that you would put on a billboard,
metaphorically speaking? Like a message, a
quote, a word. Anything at all that if you
were to get a message out to billions of people,
assuming they would understand it, what might
you put on the billboard? Anything at all.
Jason Calacanis: There's part of me that wants
to tell people to take chances and that they
can do it. Like, to give it a shot. To just
give it a shot. Right? It might just work
out. What if it works out? Give it a shot.
What if it actually works out? And then there's
another part of me that, that's my head speaking,
and then my heart is just be kind to each
other. Especially in the face of when people
are unkind. I've just noticed that people,
and this is coming from me, I mean, I'm known
for arguing with people, a brawler.
I don't know what's in the air. I don't know
if it's since Trump and this whole polarization
of the country, but I would really like to
see people be kinder to each other and just
have really open-hearted discussions with
each other. And I think your podcast, to a
lesser extent, what I'm trying to do on All-In,
I think there are roadmaps here for people
to have productive discussions with each other
that move themselves, evolve themselves and
involve humanity. I think that's why podcasting
is such a special medium. And I think you
really can have productive discussions with
people you disagree with. You can have great
relationships. You don't have to agree on
everything. You can have great friendships.
So have those productive discussions with
a big open heart and develop those friendships.
It really is the best part of life. So for
me, yeah, I don't know. The two best things
I've done in my life is have great friends
and build cool shit. So I guess that's my
billboard. "Have great friends; build cool
shit."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: Put a comma in there.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, and you know, just building
off something you just said, you can have
disagreements with good friends. And I would
go so far as to say if you're not having disagreements
or if you don't disagree on anything, someone's
not telling the truth.
Jason Calacanis: No.
Tim Ferriss: Because we're all different.
Jason Calacanis: Absolutely.
Tim Ferriss: And if you're spending time with
people who are thinking for themselves, you're
almost certainly going to have things you'll
disagree about. And that is part of the relationship,
that is an asset to the relationship. But
that also means you have to learn how to manage
conflict and resolve conflict. And do repair
also. And do repair.
Jason Calacanis: Yeah, repair.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: Wow. That's a whole 'nother
podcast.
Tim Ferriss: That's a whole 'nother podcast.
Jason Calacanis: Promise us, Tim, that you're
not going to stop. I get worried a little
bit that you're going stop doing this podcast.
You can take a break, but don't ever stop.
I mean, you're 45. If you do that, can you
imagine if you do this for another 20 years,
how great this archive of Tim Ferriss' podcast
is going to be?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: Think about the legacy.
Tim Ferriss: It's hard for me to see stopping.
I've thought about taking a break after a
billion downloads, which should happen in
the next few months, actually. And as much
as I fantasize about burning it all down and
going to live in a hut in the mountains and
growing out a beard and smoking a corn cob
pipe and reading books, as much as I fantasize
about that and doing cold plunges in a river
and running with my dog, there's a lot to
the fantasy. But I can't imagine, as you mentioned
earlier, we've had so many private conversations
and I think both of us have come away thinking,
"Fuck, why didn't we record that? That would've
actually made a fantastic conversation."
Jason Calacanis: Would've been a great ep!
Find him a podcaster.
Tim Ferriss: I'm going to be seeking out incredible,
fascinating people to have conversations with,
whether I'm doing the podcast or not. So I
might as well record them.
Jason Calacanis: It's just amazing the impact
it's had on society. I can't tell you how
many people, people don't know I know you
or that we're friends even. So then I'm at
a dinner par, oh, did you hear this podcast
by this guy with this odd thing? And all the
time you're really in pop culture in a way
that's just really impressive to me. It's
actually, you know what? I guess I'm going
through it now with All-In, to a lesser extent.
It really is a weird thing. So think about
being in people's ears, makes it incredibly
intimate.
Tim Ferriss: Very intimate. Yeah, it's very
Jason Calacanis: I think AirPods specifically,
these little things that you can fall asleep
in your ears or you have them in your ears
all the time. And the act of listening to
somebody's voice so often so consistently
has created some new phenomenon in the world.
We call it podcasting, but it's really like
this lifelong friendship you have with a personality
you've never met. It's really trippy.
Tim Ferriss: It is trippy. It's super trippy.
Jason Calacanis: Thanks for having me on.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, of course.
Jason Calacanis: I can't wait to see you.
Tim Ferriss: Can't wait to see too, man. So
people can find you —
Jason Calacanis: We're going to play some
poker.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, god. That's a whole separate
episode too. Yeah, that was —
Jason Calacanis: We'll play for charity.
Tim Ferriss: That was a poke —
Jason Calacanis: We'll play for your psychedelic
charity. That would be funny.
Tim Ferriss: All right. Perfect.
Jason Calacanis: I'm just Jason on Twitter.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, Jason on Twitter.
Jason Calacanis: Jason on Twitter.
Tim Ferriss: And anything else you'd like
to mention before we wrap up? Closing comments,
complaints, requests of the audience?
Jason Calacanis: No. As I randomly tweeted,
I don't know, six months ago I just had this
revelation, because I listened to three of
your podcasts in one weekend. I was kind of
catching up and I just like, you're a fucking
national treasure. It's just good to know
you.
Tim Ferriss: Thanks man. I really appreciate
that.
Jason Calacanis: Congratulation on just, it
wasn't always great.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. That's true.
Jason Calacanis: It was rough in the beginning
and now it's just fucking brilliant. So just
congratulations from one person who's been
grinding it for a while. It's just great to
see you at the top of your game. I told this
in a private conversation. It's just like,
I listened to your podcast. I'm like, wow.
He's on the top of his game. It's like watching
Michael Jordan or something. Just play basketball.
It's beautiful to watch and you get the best
guests. Now when you have great guests on,
they're enamored with you. And it used to
be, you're kind of like, yeah, I'm Tim Ferriss,
just kind what I'm doing. They come on and
they just want to talk about you. And I'm
like, whoa this is tipped over, hasn't it?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: Famous person.
Jason Calacanis: Is talking about your podcast,
where you're trying to interview them. Whoa.
Interesting to be Tim Ferriss. Anyway, we'll
see you all next time. Bye bye.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jason Calacanis: You've got to end this podcast
it sounds —
Tim Ferriss: No, we're going to end it.
Jason Calacanis: We tried to end it five times
this.
Tim Ferriss: I know. We tried to end it five
times.
Jason Calacanis: It's because we miss each
other.
Tim Ferriss: The tearful goodbyes. So I will
say this, Jason, thank you.
Jason Calacanis: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: It's lovely to see you. I am
studying what you're doing, so it gives me
great joy to have you on. And you've inspired
me to think about maybe trying my hand at
an experimental format with moderating a few
folks.
Jason Calacanis: Do it.
Tim Ferriss: I'll give it a go. And this has
been a blast. I've learned so much and heard
so much. I never thought that I would, never
would've expected to hear.
Jason Calacanis: Yeah, here we are.
Tim Ferriss: So happy we made it happen. And
to everybody listening, as always, we will
have links to everything we discussed in the
show notes at tim.blog/podcast and until next
time, be just a little bit kinder than you
think necessary to other people and to yourself.
Jason Calacanis: Please.
Tim Ferriss: And squeeze the shit out of that
box of oranges, because we're all going to
end up —
Jason Calacanis: Drop folks.
Tim Ferriss: We're all going to end up on
the roof as in Blade Runner. We're not going
to last forever. So make those moments count.
Jason Calacanis: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Thank you, Jason.
Jason Calacanis: I love you, brother. Love
you too. Oh, that was great, Tim.